The phone calls.
Nothing to hide.
Yeah.
And we're live ladies and gentlemen.
So just like that,
just like that bitch is,
I get a message from a friend of mine
who says that while he was listening to
the show,
we were talking about something and then
the ads for that thing started showing
up.
Yeah.
Oh God.
It's a,
it's Fong from my plastic cell.
He said you guys were talking about
slouching with the avant today and this
popped up on his feet just now.
I never googled it before.
And it's some fucking alarm that goes off.
Like when you slouch forward,
have you seen those things?
You glue them on you.
I've been getting an ad for that too.
Oh,
you have as random
coincidence could be that.
Or it could be targeting Joe Rogan
listeners do the way it works.
So they found out that
we were listening to,
they could just be going,
I mean maybe that,
but like there's a large audience here
so they could just be going after like,
oh right.
But do you think like what?
Adam Green,
she said the other day that that's
happening again talking about,
he was talking about Toyota trucks and
then all of a sudden it's Google ads
started showing up.
Toyota Tacomas and he,
and he was like,
dude,
he goes,
they're listening and
the robots are listening.
So one's listening,
but they're also looking for like
key terms and stuff like that.
But they're listening to your phone as
you're having a conversation you think?
Yes,
I have a few instances.
I took screenshots because I was,
it was happening.
It happened three,
three consecutive weeks.
I touched something.
I literally like held the object in my
hand and within 12 hours I was getting an
ad for it.
Maybe your magic bro.
It's very strange.
One of them I have with [inaudible] Bravo,
they're so weird.
It was like,
how the fuck am I getting
an ad for this thing now?
I've never even seen this.
I've never talked about it to anybody.
I didn't tell anybody I was holding it.
Yeah,
you got look for it.
Always be careful of like this idea that,
you know,
because sometimes things
are just a coincidence and
this idea that there's some
grand conspiracy when it could be
easily explained by coincidence,
but the thing that Adam said,
he said it,
he goes,
man,
I never fucking Google Toyota trucks.
Is that a good,
uh,
I was trying to get that really not bad.
Not that good.
A little British.
Hey Mike.
Um,
but he was saying that uh,
they start popping up right
after the podcast immediately.
So if that's the case,
they had to be listening to his podcast
or they are listed one of them's list
because you have a large audience,
someone from those listened to it
live and then they're just like,
dude,
they launched those ads.
Yeah,
but it has to get on his Google feed.
Yeah.
You think they spoil more
fucking crime and stuff?
If they're listening,
you don't make money spoiling crying,
Bro.
I'm like,
Eh,
make money selling trucks.
I don't know.
I mean,
I feel like for sure when I Google
something and starts popping up,
we know that,
but that seems normal.
All,
dude,
if you go on my phone right now,
because I've been looking at dodge vipers,
it anything I clicked on,
vipers pop up.
Even ads on Instagram.
Real.
Yeah.
They're just trying to get you to like,
when I look at houses in a certain house,
markets pop up.
It's weird.
They know.
Mother fuckers look at
to spend some money.
Yeah.
Speaking and spend some money forward.
Why do you hate America?
They released the new gt
500 only an automatic.
Oh my God.
What a shame.
What shame is it only automatic?
Only automatic.
I didn't know that.
I posted on my story
because some dude was like,
shop when you get one of these.
And I was like,
God,
that thing is dope.
And I posted with like a thinking face.
None of that's automatic ain't happening.
People go,
well you have a PDK gt three Rs.
It's deaf Fred.
Well it's also,
that's the only way they make it.
Well,
he's usually the way they
make the gt three Rs.
The RS.
Yeah.
I mean you could get a gt three or are I,
you know,
I get it.
People don't want to shift.
It gets stuck in traffic.
I get it.
But there's a lot of other cars
and get the GT 500 the whole,
it used to only be stick
like the gt three 50.
Well you know why they're doing it
because they want to compete with everyone
else.
Cause on the track the PDK is beat the
best racers in the world know like uh,
my brother's telling me about this uh,
article he was reading where I,
I think it was the,
the new gt three Rs and um,
or maybe was the,
it was the new gt three
cause there's one in PDK,
there's one in stick,
one of the best race car drivers in
the world driving the stick shift.
Then they had some average
dumb ass driving the PDK
and they're going around the
track and the PDK smoke.
This dude,
the guy with a stick shift smoked him.
Yeah.
But what are you trying to do if you'd
just trying to buy a car for the track?
I get it.
But how many people are
buying a car for the track?
You're looking at him,
Bro.
I race on the track and I don't,
I have no idea.
I don't give a shit.
I just liked the feeling.
Um,
and it's,
it's kind of link cause
I have that slingshot,
the polar slingshot and that stick shift
and that's like a tricky stick shift.
Well that's that little tiny cage.
Dang wheels dangerous as shit.
But because the stick shift,
I like not being able to
pay attention to my phone.
I like having to worry about
all the cars around me.
Like I liked that feeling.
I like the feeling of the road and
the stick shift and I dig that.
I want that in a car now.
Yeah.
I that,
that's how my corvette is.
My court,
that little 65 corvette,
that thing's so small.
Pumps some life.
India though.
Oh God.
You drive it to the store all the time.
Yeah,
we shut right.
Yeah.
Wakes you up.
Well it's so loud.
It's good side pipes.
It's a stick shift.
Big Old Hearst fucking
cue ball on the top.
That's what you want.
That's what they used
to have with a gt 500.
I had a gt 500 way back
in 2012 that was glorious.
Big Old rumbly fucking,
I had a convertible to hell.
Yeah.
Damn right.
You know,
Blah Blah Blah.
It was great.
Put the top down loud as fuck.
But also we get,
we get too comfy with the,
with the,
you know,
if you have your,
you drive your fricking m five so
cushy and everything's kind of,
there it is.
I think it looks dope as shit.
Look at the front view,
the seat.
Go with a silver gt.
500 pull that up.
There's a shitload of
carbon fiber in it now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
There's a bunch of shit like the
splitter and a bunch of the aero stuff.
They'll hit that one right there.
Look at that.
Oh,
that looks so healthy.
That looks so good.
I love it.
It's a goddamn automatic.
Like why did they do that?
Like just to compete man.
So when you look on
motor trend as an option,
I agree.
I,
but to have it as an option.
Yeah.
Having it as an option and they give
you a skirt when you climb into it.
It said the transmission was
made specifically for this car.
Yes.
Just to get performance out of it.
That's all they want is the performance.
So they can say,
hey,
this competes with,
you know,
I would still drive that even
though it's an automatic oh,
driving as a daily driver.
Yeah,
I agree.
I would 750 horsepower
dailies at seven 57 it says.
Oh it is.
Yeah.
I think it's probably pretty light.
All the carbon fiber,
the things up.
No fucking rocket check the way Jamie.
I bet it's 3,900 pounds easy.
Do you think it's almost 4,000 no way.
Yeah,
I bet it is.
Several of the cushy shit in it.
16 you know,
mid three seconds.
Zero to 60 yeah,
I bet it's a 3,900 pounds.
Google a g 53 50 a GT,
three 50 are,
they'll have the curb weight on a,
if there's a bunch of carbon fiber,
something of me that that carbon fiber,
that's a pretty cushy mostly for looks.
No.
Yeah.
It's so strong,
dude.
Yeah,
but it's mostly for,
looks like it's not making it that much
light at 3,700 pounds and that's the
most track ready one.
So this is going to be heavier than
the GT three 50 because it has a
supercharger on it.
The supercharger and all that other
jazz is probably about a hundred pounds.
So yeah,
I think so.
Robert?
800 pounds.
3,700 yeah,
for that one.
But that's the three 50 to three
the gt 500 has a a a big ass whipple
supercharger on it to
make it even heavier.
Sound so good though.
You were here a supercharger whine.
Fuck.
Yay.
That's American power though.
You know,
they're not light.
They're heavy,
you know big ass engines.
Well that's the thing.
It's like that's what you
want kind of in there.
They're trying to make a muscle car,
a precision scalpel instrument,
like a nine 11 gt three it's not that.
It's a different thing.
It's not where we're looking for
like the white car that I have,
the gt three Rs,
the shark works car,
that car is a scalpel.
It's precision.
It's effortless the way it handles and
maneuvers and it's just a different
experience.
But a muscle car is
supposed to thrill you.
Supposed to be exciting.
Yeah.
You don't want to,
yeah.
It's not going to beat
any fucking track town.
You know you care.
You're not trying to,
I mean,
what do you Nicholas cage
and gone in 60 seconds.
My brother always says that streetcar car.
I'm like,
my thing would beat the
shit of that and he's like,
not on the track though.
I'm like,
ah,
I'm on the five.
I don't fuck he's old.
I look like on the track.
I know it's so a irresponsible to
even be able to sell these cars.
Like when they're selling these Corvettes,
these new corvette zr
one with 757 horsepower.
They have a sub three seconds,
zero to 60 it's like 2.6 seconds.
There needs to be like an Iq test for
that thing name and a driving test like
what do you believe in flat earth.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
what was it about that pizza gate
that new Tesla roadster is going to
be zero to 60 in under two seconds.
That's trouble because
every moron that doesn't,
oh,
cars getting Tesla because it's like the
new Prius cool thing to do and so they
get those things and they're
fucking lightning rods.
Lightening.
I can't,
I just,
I know I'm super old school.
I can't fuck with them.
I don't like them.
I getting calendar.
That bumps me out.
That's just not for me,
man.
I just,
I don't,
I like the sound of an engine.
I like,
I don't know.
I don't like,
yeah,
you feel like you're driving an iPod.
I don't care how fucking fast it goes.
It's just,
it does nothing for me.
Callen goes back and forth
from complaining about it
to tell you how you should
get one.
Oh,
I know.
It's very strange.
It depends what day you catch them.
It depends which day it is.
It's like he's tried to talk you into it.
It's like he's so,
he doesn't feel alone now.
Cause like I love that thing.
I fucking love that thing.
The next day it's like,
I don't do that thing,
the charge.
I just don't know man.
Well,
there you go.
Should I get a Porsche you?
She'll be like,
you and Joe.
Should I get a Porsche?
I'm like,
Shit.
I be like,
Oh man,
he should get something that's reliable
that he could drive around everywhere
that you know,
like a BMW or something?
Yeah.
Like you should just
get like a five series,
three series.
But as ego won't let
them and he's a big car.
Really?
Oh,
he won't get a small car now.
Why does it need a big car?
You know?
Okay.
It's Callen man.
Your life is a big car.
Well,
yeah,
he wants to be manly.
You know he's not going to get
jars or mammy before to him.
Brian,
he wants to be manly.
Why would he get a car?
It doesn't make any noise because
he's even thinking about that.
He doesn't care about like dual.
If you ask him what dual exhaust is,
he booked half an idea.
He doesn't know what dual exhaust.
No,
it's fucking,
he's not into that stuff.
Those two times.
You know what happened?
He took a chance the way back in the day.
I want to say like 2000
fucking two or three.
He had a Ford Bronco like 1969.
Oh hell ago.
It was bad ass,
but really?
Yeah.
But it stunk.
It was one of them old school ones.
It wasn't like an icon one.
It was an old school one
with a carburetor and shit.
So you smelled gas fumes everywhere.
He loved it.
Didn't have any doors and it
didn't have a top Kallin had this,
it was dope.
Yeah.
Give it to him.
But he didn't know I bought it.
Yes he did.
Yeah.
He decided he was a wild man and
he was going to drive around it.
Um,
it was a stick shift,
stick shift.
Uh,
pretty sure the stick shift.
Ford Bronco,
early Bronco and put his
pit bull in the back.
Yeah.
It has a tank top old man
living on Venice beach,
single single guy taken down if free
buddy insight just out there on the,
on the freak prowl,
just dropping loads
all over Venice and uh,
couldn't,
couldn't keep it up.
I got,
I was looking up the roadster.
This is a Audi's new thing
that they just announced.
It's called the P be 18 Jesus Christ.
That's an electric car in a arrival.
The roadster,
same speed is what they're sorta claiming.
It will go a zero to 60
in just under two seconds.
Jesus starts getting too fat.
Look how good it looks though.
It charges in 15 minutes,
but yeah.
What?
Yeah.
How the fuck is that possible?
Because the Germans said,
oh Tesla,
you're making cars.
Very cool.
Let us try as this coming out,
there's only going to be about 50 of them,
mate.
Fuck you.
You fuck sons of bitches again,
even that like it looks dope,
but because I'd rather have,
you know the r eight with a a gas inches,
a beastly looking spaceship of
a video looks pretty much like,
oh,
it's got a seat in the center.
Yeah,
I see.
you get one seat.
I like that.
I took that.
If you got a girlfriend,
you told her to sit in the
backseat and rub my neck.
CanNot kick rocks,
bitch.
Get an Uber meets you there.
Doesn't have a backseat.
We take off.
You can't peel rubber and those things.
You just go fucking filthy though.
It has a dirty,
yeah,
I bet they're going to
come out of the gas pedal.
Right.
It looks just the same.
Well apparently people are taking the
ACURA NSX and they're replacing their
other,
doing something to the
boots are replacing the ECU.
So they're uh,
changing the,
the,
the program that they use to,
to,
you know,
and using the changing,
using a aftermarket exhaust and
just Jack in a horse and stores.
It's what you do with those.
Did I fucking knew Nsx
is a beast of a car mat?
They're cool.
I didn't realize how
small they were though.
I one pulled up to me the other night.
It was like revenues in general.
Like,
dude,
we're not doing this.
I don't know.
I'm 35 years old.
We're not.
Um,
and he was a grown man to,
this is off sunset was
coming home from the store.
No Brag about it to blew bloom
off the line at the red light.
I don't like what are going to do,
man,
I don't get this.
But I didn't realize
how small they were now.
Yeah,
they're pretty little.
it was.
The old ones are real little.
That's what it looks like now.
That's a diff,
that's a deep red.
Oh,
I like that.
What's the guards red?
It's a Porsche.
Could look in car.
Goddammit.
It's cool.
That's very McLaren.
Ish.
Yeah,
a little bit.
Well,
it's there.
They're making them spaceshipy you know,
dude,
there was a,
I was in Edmonton this past
weekend freezing at the giant mall,
but in the middle of the mall there's a
McLaren and you know that malls filled
with kids.
Cause there's wave pools and dolphin.
There's all sorts of shit there.
It's the biggest mall in North America.
And this poor Mclaren,
it was hurting my feelings.
Cause there's,
there's kids everywhere.
They don't give a fuck about the MC Lynn.
They're yanking on the
fucking mirrors is awesome.
Kick kick in the back.
I'm like,
dude,
what are you guys doing?
It's just parked in the middle.
Just says like,
uh,
you know,
like a showcase car.
Don't even have a rose.
They're on it all the no ropes,
nothing.
Kids wiping their shitty sticky
fingers in it and picking their nose,
right.
Boogers in Lego's,
just fucking edge and their
names and the side and shit.
I know,
I was like,
come on,
make laryngeal or pride on why would they
let pull that taste usually sell on a
lot of Mclaren's and Edmonton.
I don't know.
It is that oil money starts
to burn a hole in your pocket.
A lot of those guys up there in Alberta,
they get those jobs,
which are tough fucking jobs.
The oil,
all my great hard work,
hard work,
but big money.
Um,
my friend John Rivet
and his wife Jen there,
their son was doing it for awhile.
Kind of a bad business to be in though.
Right?
So it's oil is kind of on the way out.
Uh,
not up there,
I think.
I think it's,
I think it's down though.
I know.
I know it's down because
the economy there,
uh,
one of the drivers was telling me,
he's like,
yeah,
well it's just not what it's,
you know,
it's a fraction of the price
than what it was a year ago,
two years ago.
Oh really?
So we're taking hits from it can imagine
if that was like your business and your
business could just fluctuate that
hard like all of a sudden and down.
It's just useless.
Well,
cause eventually it's going to be useless.
[inaudible] our lifetime.
Well not with assholes.
I guess it don't want
to drive electric cars.
I know.
I think about the whole tie
thing about it with my son,
like God help this little perk isn't
just driving Teslas everywhere.
Like I want to educate
them on Topaz rights,
but that's fucking at the planet.
But also is it?
It is.
You think?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
So then we should be in electric.
It's having an effect.
Yeah.
But the question is how much of an effect,
what is having the most effect?
There's a lot of different things that
are having an effect and what's our
footprint and that effect.
You know what I'm saying?
There's a lot.
I mean,
human beings,
there's a lot of us and we're definitely
burning a lot of shit and putting a lot
of carbon into the
atmosphere and there's a,
there's definitely an impact.
Well,
it starts with the eyes and impact.
It's crazy.
The core,
the real question is how much of an
impact and can it be turned around and uh,
how much,
how much of a bad thing is it actually,
because somewhere in the,
it's in the middle of,
there's,
you got your ultimate doom
and gloom people that are all,
they're saying that all of the
city's going to be underwater.
Fucking east coast can be underwater.
The west coast could be underwater.
Everyone's fucked.
And then you've got the
other people that say,
no,
we're just going to be able
to move it in northern Canada.
Jesus Christ,
the of the people who
think that you could just,
we're just going to have up there
beautiful spots in Antarctica.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Maybe somewhere in the middle.
Huh?
It's somewhere in the middle.
Somewhere in the middle.
I'm a middle guy.
The Real,
uh,
optimist think that we're going to be
able to take some of the carbon out of the
atmosphere and the way they're
going to be able to do it.
They actually invented this
giant that looks like a building.
It's like a building size machine that's
like a huge air filter that just sucks
carbon out of the air.
I think they did it since,
I think it's a Chinese
thing and I think they,
they're,
they're installing them somewhere in
China because you know like when the
athletes were in Beijing for the Olympics,
they said the air and my God,
the air quality was like smoking
a pack of cigarettes a day.
Dude,
you don't realize how important the
air quality is till when those fires.
I was doing shows in Sacramento.
I didn't even think of it.
Pete and fans or a DM,
are you going to do,
are you going to cancel?
Please don't cancel.
I'm like,
why the fuck would I cancel a night?
I don't cancel shows.
I'll see sin man.
Then I fly in and I was like,
Oh shit.
You couldn't see a foot
in front of your face.
She sent me a smoke.
You sent me a picture from
your hotel room and I was like,
is there a fire in your room?
I've never seen anything like it and I
did not feel good off sick the whole time
there to my shows,
US lightheaded,
everyone had mass gone
like Asians at airports.
Everybody set for me and my brother.
And guess what?
We couldn't get any mass
cause they're all sold out.
Did they help?
Yeah,
I think so.
They filter some of it,
but I didn't realize
how big of a deal was.
Ty went up there and I'm like,
Holy Shit Man,
this is,
this is serious.
Those fires were so big.
The mean the fires down here,
we're big but nothing compared to the
northern California fires because of the
area of northern California
that got lit up was like woods,
like huge,
huge wooded areas.
And the whole town was just,
it's not there anymore.
It was a paradise done.
Game over does.
No,
nothing's,
nothing.
The whole town burned down British.
Sure go to that.
Pull up paradise.
california.com.
Is that a,
is that a place that I
want to sit down now?
Do you see?
They fired the Frickin uh,
some of the firefighters in like a relief
people cause they were taking pictures
like not even mock and I don't think they
should have been fired because it was
like all burnt down house
and then there's like,
I don't know,
like a wooden horse and then
like firefighters like on
the wooden horse and like
go like your mark mocking the
people lost their homes and they,
oh they lost their jobs.
That's crazy.
Come on man.
This guys are fighting
for their life out there.
That probably just to do with it.
Not only that,
the,
the horses there,
it's like,
well what do you give a shit?
Why?
Why the,
the house is burned to the ground.
You really think it's that in that poor
taste for these poor guys who risked
their lives to save people's
houses to have a good time.
Why was that real?
This is crazy.
I should have made it out of those trees.
Trees are still standing in.
The trees are pretty gangster.
What's going on?
Like at a certain point in time we're
going to have to make fireproof houses.
Does that exist?
Yes.
Making them out of cinder
block or you got to do what?
Kanye didn't just have your
own fricking fire department.
Just surround your house just in case.
That's a good move.
In my neighborhood,
there's a house that burnt to the ground.
I put pictures of it up on my
Instagram as a car in the driveway.
But the,
um,
this is,
this picture is terrifying.
Oh Dude.
You're talking Armageddon style.
This fixture is terrifying.
Is this what we're looking at
as rows of houses that are gone?
That looks like it goes
for an entire neighborhood.
It's an entire neighborhood.
Why second mile and just
there's nothing left.
Everything's burnt to the ground,
but it's amazing.
Those trees are still standing.
Look at those trees there.
I mean,
their torch,
but yeah,
they're there.
Yeah,
but it's weird.
Black as fuck.
Isn't it weird?
Wouldn't you expect the trees
would be burnt to a crisp?
Yeah,
they're so thick.
The other thing is,
uh,
where's that coming from?
Ed.
I flew down.
So from north to south and when you go
over Malibu and like in Woodland Hills
and where you live,
you wouldn't bell kit.
When you see all that,
it's insane.
From a bird's eye view,
you can just see all the
black women flying into La.
Well,
I flew over a Malibu with
burr and a helicopter,
so we got real low.
It was,
it's crazy.
Crazy.
We get this Mcdonald's
burnt to the ground.
That's crazy.
You know that motherfucker
burned when cheese,
that bridge burnt well,
I like this thought of
before and after steel.
Well it's not.
It's wooden.
That was a,
what was it?
A wooden bridge wouldn't
look at this like the whole,
everything's gone.
So is that the case that the
whole town is evaporated?
Ice Is gone.
Yeah,
pretty sure.
Paradise is what the fuck those people
do now the do you don't rebuild,
right?
You're like,
wow,
Jesus.
Then also a lot of it in this,
just from my own experience down here,
I'm looking at homes in
areas where there's chances
of fire that were caused by
fires.
Banks won't give you the loan
or you have to put a higher,
almost all cash payment down
real [inaudible] and also
the house insurance on a
fire area.
They're not going to do it these days.
But what are they going to
do with a place like Malibu?
Because Malibu got hit
harder than anything.
They lost 600 plus houses.
Find out.
That's true.
I know they said they
lost like 1500 structures,
but someone told me that
600 of those warehouses,
and if you're talking about Malibu,
like when Burt and I were flying
around the coastline over by zoom,
uh,
point doom,
you know those beautiful beach there?
Well James Beach,
I don't know,
it's the cliffs fire.
Worst fired to hit Malibu with
home loss is topping 1.6 billion.
Bubba,
Bubba billion,
620 structures destroyed.
I feel like we don't hear about it
so much because I think people assume
everyone Malibu has money.
They are a higher tax bracket
so that God will figure it out.
It's still super fucked up,
man.
Well,
I have friends that don't
have a lot of money,
but they build houses and one of them,
one of the houses they were living in and
the other house they were building and
they're all the,
both houses got torched.
400 single family houses with an
estimated market value of 1.6 billion.
So 670 structures,
400 of them were houses.
That's horrible man.
Whew.
It's a weird to fly over man when
you fly over it because in the,
with a helicopter,
you know,
[inaudible] was pretty close.
We were,
we were,
you know,
right above it and circling,
just outside right over the ocean and
as you do an it flying over the ocean,
you're looking at these compounds.
They are probably $50 million houses.
I mean these fucking massive,
massive compounds burnt to the ground.
Not a goddamn thing
they could do about it.
How good of a pilot is burr?
Terrible.
We almost died three times.
Jesus Christ.
No,
he's great.
Is He?
Yeah,
he's crazy.
So he could have it that he's
been doing it for a while.
When I saw that picks on my cal,
I trust that guy 100% and if he told me
that he was going to take me up in the
helicopter,
he knows how to do it.
Yeah,
it was a good time,
man.
We had fun.
We had a lot of laughs.
Is it fun?
So much fun.
You're,
you're up in a helicopter.
Was one of the greatest comedians that
ever lived where having a good fucking
time were just howling.
Me and him.
He's hilarious.
And we talk it through headphones cause
it's like [inaudible] so you got a
little little fucking
like command or some shit.
Hell yeah.
That's sick and microphone in the corner.
I don't know.
Helicopters scare me man.
It was a good time.
Yeah,
I saw that.
Scared the fuck out of me.
It's weird how close you
can get to downtown La.
Like you're not,
there's no real restrictions.
You just fly right next to the building.
So I'm like this is okay
because it's a helicopter.
Yeah.
That was us right there.
We just flying around.
I mean,
we were just flying right next to these
buildings and we were the height of the
buildings and all those two buildings,
see those flat spots
and all those buildings.
Those are all helicopter pads.
Landing Pads,
Huh?
Yeah.
And some of them are
real narrow and bills.
Like I wouldn't want to lend on
that fucking thing on a windy day.
And I'm like,
oh my God,
I don't even think about hold up.
It was just you and bird.
There's no,
it was the third guy lies the third guy.
Yeah.
The third guy was a um,
um,
you know an instructor.
He's the guy that bill
that teaches bill but bill.
Gotcha.
But bill can fly solo.
He has a license to fly solo.
He flies a lot,
right?
Yeah.
He flies.
God,
I'd just not into that.
I think it'd be awesome
to get up there and do it.
It's just not pros and cons,
man.
Pros you fly around a little bit,
get real high con die.
Yeah.
But it seemed pretty controlled.
It really does.
But there's no like
there's no room for error,
you know what I'm saying?
But like unless you're Harrison Ford,
he crashed and Santa Monica to be
crashed a plane straight up plain.
Yeah.
Helicopter Santa Monica crashed.
Where'd he crashed?
Uh,
I forget.
Looked that up Jamie.
He flew out of Santa Monica
airport and it was like,
ah,
fuck it went down because
he's so high all the time.
I hear is he really?
Oh Dude,
he smokes like fuck and
Cheech and Chong Bro.
You smoke weed for Harrison
Ford blazes that up.
I think when you get that famous,
you probably just want to be high all
the time because life is a dream anyway.
He just like,
I just think there's nothing else to,
and he's just like,
I don't know man.
That doesn't keep you busy.
30 years ago,
we just did one a couple of years ago.
Had a cameo in it.
He wasn't like the main guy.
That's why people were pissed.
Right.
He got Merkt did he?
I'm not star wars guy.
Dude.
That came out forever ago.
Spoiler alert.
There is for everything
as a spoiler it now.
Oh Dude.
People are seeing game of
Thrones now for the first time.
There's dragons assholes.
It's like with that Dannemora escape.
I've seen that on showtime.
It's about,
you know those two guys.
Harrison Ford saved several lives
by landing plane on golf course.
That,
what the fuck does that mean?
Scroll down where that kind of fucking,
there you go and fucking
hand sell low Indiana Jones.
But you know what?
Just walked away.
Went fuck this noise.
I'm looking where he crashed
and how the plane went down.
I'm sure there was a moment where he said,
I'm not going to risk lives.
Whatever happens,
happens.
It's going to be just me.
72 year old actor suffered moderate
injuries after crashing the vehicle.
The vintage to Cedar Poe huskies
find a fucking old plane,
a vintage plane that he
was piloting on the green.
Uh,
on the golf course Thursday afternoon.
He had lacerations to his
face and possible fractures.
Television news footage taken,
showed him on a stretcher
being taken into an ambulance.
Dude,
he risked life and limb by putting it
down on the golf course instead of trying
to go further,
try to get back to the airport.
Notice how Harrison Ford,
he's not quoted anything.
He didn't give a fuck.
How about,
uh,
we were on the Fox lot.
Brian and I were,
when we worked for Fox and uh,
this Tesla pulls in and it's all tinted
windows and it rolled down the window.
It's Harrison Ford.
And I go,
I tell Brian you,
oh shit,
that's fucking Indiana Jones.
Like joking around.
And Brian,
I didn't know how big of a Harrison
Ford Fanny's Brian gets super.
It never seemed like
this gets super nervous.
And Harrison s and Brian,
he was like this.
It gives them the peace sign.
I've never seen a grown man give
another grown man a peace sign.
Here's the forest she likes them.
Just cause tells you
acknowledged the piece.
I'm just keeps on going,
Yo Bro,
you just gave deuces to
fucking Indiana Jones.
I will do that.
It was so great.
Here's a four.
Didn't get signed.
The people do.
What are we,
what do you think that alien,
they'd be coming peas.
You go like this.
Y'All do that.
You know what?
I do those good.
I do like this weekend we'll know.
This is Kinda like Yo,
like not a wave,
but this,
this is kind of halt.
This is,
I'm reaching for you,
reaching for you.
And then if you go too high,
it's the Hail Hitler.
You don't want that.
So you gotta tell you,
man,
I'm now I'm thinking I give peace
signs of people all the time.
You do this all the time.
Like a 14 year old Korea up teenager girl.
Yup.
Exactly.
13,
13 year old teenager girl.
Peace,
peace out.
Nothing the wrong with that.
My kids to hear all the time,
but they do sideways like this.
They'll take pictures.
They were like,
that's,
that's cute.
Lips out though.
They'll do like this.
Hand forward,
this hand backward.
You know they do like this.
Yes.
Well that's what Brian did.
Harrison Ford.
Look at that picture right there.
That's me Bro.
Put a match and running up to
here some four to doing that.
Freaked him the fuck out
and he's high off his ass.
Yeah,
I was driving that fucking
electric Dune buggy.
It was great man.
Yeah.
He's,
um,
I wonder what he does with his
spare time other than fly planes,
but can you make that much money and
you're that famous and then you just sit
around,
what do you do?
I don't know,
but there's,
there's certain guys at that level,
right?
Like he's so famous.
He's a whole nother level.
But I was thinking about last night,
Dave,
when Dave Chappelle
walked in and it was like,
you know,
you're around birds around,
there's some of the greatest
comics in the world.
Then when Dave Chappelle walks in,
I wonder if it's weird for him
because I can feel the room,
like everyone just stares
at him and he was in the or,
and I was in there before
he went on and there's,
I mean,
there wasn't a seat.
I mean people are in the hallways.
There's just watch him do
his thing and he's just,
he was up there,
I don't know,
an hour,
two hours,
just not really doing a set,
just feeling it out.
I went,
man,
that must be weird at where he's
at in life that he just goes up.
Then it's like the everything
shuts down for him as a comic.
Like he's not working out right.
You know what I'm saying?
Well,
he's definitely working out.
No,
that's not correct,
but it's different than if somebody else
like all eyes are on them all the time
nonstop.
So even him working out,
it's funny as fuck,
you know?
Well he,
he handles it remarkably well.
Like the way he just around people like
even though he's super duper ridiculous,
famous,
he handles it like he's
not wanders through.
But man,
when people start grabbing Adam
and wanting pictures and shit,
it's so embarrassing.
Oh,
they just,
they won't let them talk to people.
Like say if you're talking to them,
they don't care if you're in a locked in
a conversation about your mom's cancer,
they don't care.
They're just,
Yo Bro,
can I get a picture?
The day health freak out,
they freak out.
This is my time to dress
up my Facebook page.
And they get there with
that and they just liked,
they move in on him like a fucking hawk.
It's just,
it's embarrassing.
It's embarrassing.
People don't respect another
person having a conversation.
They don't wait like no
one sits around and wait.
It's like in their head.
If they don't grab them right now,
they're never going to get that picture.
So it doesn't matter who he's talking to.
These,
I've seen it too.
Like I was talking to the rock once and
this dude literally slid in between us
and held his phone up to the rock
slid in between is it just didn't ask.
He was taking the picture as he was asking
these two pictures with you and just
like in between us like I'm talking to,
hey what's up and you have a good
time but blah blah blah blah.
And then this guy slides in.
It's got the camera up like no thought
whatsoever for people's and what did the
rock do?
He's probably used to it by
swallowed saying Jesus Christ.
I handled it like a man.
It's just such a bummer man.
It is.
Cause there's a certain
point of fame with Chappelle,
the rock.
You're probably pretty fucking close
at where you came and go through the
airport.
Like I have to go through the
airport one time with Tim Tebow.
Um,
right.
I think right,
right after he went like
this huge playoff game.
Does he get on a knee
before he gets on a plane?
Now he assumes Jesus is taken care of him.
Oh yeah.
Jesus take the wheel.
And I knew I was safe
as fuck next to himself.
I didn't give a fuck.
So going through the
report with him and um,
I,
I felt bad for him.
I mean,
you're talking,
you can't,
you can't get anywhere.
It was just like these,
this mob do,
this is exhausting.
Exhausting.
There's to be a certain level
where that's just not cool man.
Well,
when,
what change was phones?
Cameras on phones and then social media
because everybody wants a picture.
Whereas before,
I guess people would just want autographs
and no one had a camera with them.
Now the autograph is the Selfie.
Yeah.
There's no more audit.
Is that something you get?
Like there might be a
few that had a show off,
but once I said,
I'm literally so cute with your death
for an autograph because the other day,
but it's like a hundred to
one pictures of herself.
It's all self.
Yeah.
It's all selfies.
It's weird.
It's strange.
This is the life we chose.
This is a weird world we live in.
Well take it easy.
You know I'm not Tim Teebo fricking Joe.
Like you can walk through
an airport bomb done.
Yeah,
I could walk through an airport.
it gets weird,
but I can do it.
But like Chapelle it'd be tough.
Yeah.
Well Tom Cruise,
that motherfucker can't
walk through an airport.
Yeah,
but you're Tom Cruise.
You get Tom Cruise money,
you go private.
Lax.
He laughs.
Like that's the best joke.
He's heard that you bring
up lax or Tom Cruise.
What's up?
Fuck on Bro.
Well we flew over there
when we were with Berger.
Yeah.
The,
the van Nuys Airport flew over
the Tom Cruise experience.
I feel like he autographs,
his jet does have like his
signature on his jet has a button.
You can press and then it's all covered
in screens and it turns into the clouds
behind it and becomes invisible.
Wonder woman.
Makes Sense.
It's fucking Tom Cruise Fan,
but don't you think that guy
has probably a lot of expenses?
I always assumed that a guy like that,
not only do they have a lot of money,
but they burned through a lot of money
so they have to keep making a lot of
money.
Is that true though?
Or are we assuming everyone's Johnny
Depp and has 19 houses and buying old
pirate ships were $30 billion.
You know what I'm saying?
And then just making
horrible life decisions.
Like that's the same thing with,
with like athletes or even
comics or entertainers.
Like if I post something
and say I post my car,
somebody that like,
good luck bro,
in three years when you go broke.
I'm like,
no,
I know the bad stories.
I get that man.
I'm a smart dude.
Like I,
I think I've made it this far.
And listen to those people.
They just hope you're going broke.
No,
but there's that stigma of
like the 30 for 30 ESPN broke.
It's like not,
that's not everyone's like that man.
Hate to tell you.
Not all entertainers are our fucking
rappers where we're just blowing through
money.
They,
it doesn't work like that.
I'm in a business where it's not,
you know,
it's not just like,
it's,
it's not the UFC where your average
careers a year and a half or two years,
you know,
the world of podcasting,
podcasting is a weird thing,
right?
It's like,
what are we doing?
We're just talking,
you know,
this is what our,
our,
our art form is shit people already do.
You know?
Yeah.
That's weird.
If you think about it,
it's very weird.
You know,
there's no other art form
where everybody does it.
Every what?
Every company does it.
Not everybody paints.
No.
But when was the last time you painted?
Well,
I paint with my son on your own was the
last time you went down to Michael's
canvas?
Never.
Cause I don't suck.
Tick.
I get out.
I can't pay for a lot of
painters that don't Suck Dick.
You,
you'd be surprised.
But there are,
but I'm talking about like,
uh,
like taking time out of
my data kind of flower,
the rose sexual male
painters that admire you,
that are listening to this.
Right.
I love you guys man.
Cool Bro.
Paint brush in their hand
right now and they're like,
fuck this guy.
I'm going to paint shop with
a big old Dick in his mouth.
Do it.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I went with podcasts is,
it's weird,
but it's also the gateway to a,
an unfiltered medium where before
with TV and movies and stuff like,
you know,
with like a name,
any big guy,
um,
who's who,
I'm trying to think of a,
uh,
like Dax Shepard,
right?
He's a,
he's an actor.
He's an actor and he has a podcast.
Well,
if you just watch his movies,
you don't know shit about him.
Right?
He's playing a character,
but you can go on his pockets.
You have some toxic,
I'll fuck.
We're in a lot of the same things.
Oh Damn.
He's struggling with his wife.
God,
I have the same issues.
Oh Damn.
He's struggling with his kids.
And then you find out
where all the exact same,
but you'd never get that
if there weren't podcasts,
you wouldn't.
You're not going to get that off
of ESPN interview off of 31st.
You're not going to get any of that ever.
That's my podcast and is taken over.
I think.
Well,
it's also because no one
could tell you what to do.
You know you can have
conversations that no one can,
no one can steer.
No one can.
There's no executives going
to come in and stop you.
If you fuck up,
it's your fuck up.
And then if you apologize,
an apology that you make yourself,
you,
you don't feel good about what you did.
You want you express remorse,
which I do all the time.
That's the way to go though.
Like I took a lot of shit.
I don't want to say shit.
I just,
I go and then,
then I'll think about
something like with Novitsky,
right?
I like Jeff [inaudible].
I really like a metal.
The onetime met him.
He's great dude.
We had a joke about it.
The nickname,
the golden snitch.
Like good dude.
Look right there.
Right next to you.
Oh,
this the shirt.
Yeah.
Oh Dude.
Thank you Jen.
I will rock the shit out of that.
I get that.
That's pretty dope.
Hold that up for the camera.
Was Pretty Dope for sure.
Let me or Joe Design their shirts.
But that's a good sheriff.
It's a decent shirt.
I like it a lot.
Yeah,
it's cool.
Um,
but like with him,
right?
Like I go off on something
and then when I talked to you about it,
I'm like,
I don't want to hurt anyone's feelings.
It's just like,
to me it's a,
it's a,
it's a gay and then,
but when you think about like [inaudible]
he might have to deal with it in the
office.
People are like,
dude,
her shop this or gets DM this or you know,
I'm like,
I don't want that.
It's the last thing I want.
Well you just,
you made an error in that you thought
that he worked for Usada and he'd never
worked for Usada although
worked for the UFC.
You said he worked for the east
side and now he works with UFC,
but he never really worked for Usada.
He wasn't where the
government very closely with
[inaudible] who worked for the
UFC where for the UFC and
he brought over to the UFC.
Now he know he coordinated the UFC.
He's meeting with Usada
and he put it all together.
He's the vice president of
us of a athletes' safety,
health and safety's.
I would,
it is something like that for the UFC.
That's what he's always had that before
that he worked for the government.
Yes,
but he,
he's worked hand in hand with Usada.
Not as an employee,
but he never worked for Usada.
No,
he's never worked with,
he went from,
I think he was working for the IRS.
Pretty sure.
Mm.
Yeah.
My point was,
yeah,
he's not,
he's never got it.
I don't know if he's ever
gotten a check from the Sada,
but he's been in cahoots with them.
They worked hand in hand.
FDA.
That's it.
Yeah.
That's when he wasn't at his job.
Lance Armstrong,
right?
Yeah.
Every time I talked to Novitsky,
I get text messages from land.
So I'm sure it makes sense though.
Right?
So salty.
Why wouldn't you be,
I mean you kidding me?
Wow.
I see why he would be salty.
But I also,
he has to accept,
I think that he did some things
that he shouldn't have done.
And I'm not even just
talking about the steroids.
I'm talking about suing the people
that came out and said that he took the
stairs.
That's where he's fucked up
because just doing pds in uh,
in a cycling dirty,
don't give a fuck.
Do it bro.
And you're the best at it.
He's still would have been the
best of the level playing field.
I think so too.
So,
but the way he fucked up his use mean
and bullied the people that we're trying
to snitch on him or,
or if they weren't into the pds or
if they were going to tell on him,
he kind of fucked them over.
That's where it gets dark and
that's where people hate them.
So I get that.
But in his defense,
and then this is a shaky defense.
They went after those
people to get to him.
They went after those people and
they broke those people down there,
made those people rat on him and then he
was threatening them with lawsuits sort
of to protect himself.
But even before that,
right,
I did there,
there's a little bit of a
bully culture coming from him,
which is why everyone
competitors a mean guy,
you know,
a lot of like most people are.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right about that.
I was just talking about this
the other day and it in this,
Tj Dillashaw is a great
guy and he fight Saturday,
um,
great guy,
but he's mean,
correct.
Great Guy.
But if you say,
Hey Tj,
if you knock him out with a head kick,
his family won't eat tonight.
In order for you to win this fight,
he's going to knock you
out with a head kick.
He's the most ultra
competitive guy in the world
and it shows in training
shows in practice.
I mean,
he's a nasty motherfucker.
Do you know him?
He was 135 pounds right now.
Oh yeah.
He's ready to go.
But he got his body down to 135
pounds before the weight cut.
It's Craig.
He looks so thin freak.
I saw him on ESPN last night
and they were discussing it.
He might fight Max or he
wants to fight Max next.
He wants to fight one 45 after this.
But that's a 20 pound jumping weight and
Max is a giant 45 or that's a bad idea.
But you never know what Tj,
hey,
who knows mean if he can get
his body up to one 65 dude,
have you seen the Henry?
So Hutto jacked Pico,
Pico pose.
Just kidding.
He's gonna clear the test.
I'm just joking around,
but he looks like he's pulsing.
Yeah.
He might not make weight.
He's Jack City,
Bro.
Yeah.
I don't know if he's
going to make the weight.
Oh,
I bet he makes it.
I bet he's never,
he's missed a bunch of times Henry.
So who Hutto at one 25?
Yes.
That's why they made him
fight at one 35 for a while.
Uh,
while you do doing your
shit a bunch though.
More than once.
Yeah,
that's a problem.
Look at him.
Looks pretty stacked.
Could look in,
kiss it thick,
dude.
He's a short dude.
Didn't that?
He's probably walking around at
more than 45 I would say it's
more than 40 and he's so short.
I don't know.
Yeah,
I still think he's more
than a hundred years.
That's a tough life.
If you're that short and
you're not an Olympic champion,
UFC,
right?
Like I was looking at him
the other day in a video.
I'm like,
God damn,
he's dying.
What does e five two five two five,
three I'm only five inches away from that.
I'm barely five inches.
That's a lifetime for those five inches
in which money they would pay to have
five inches.
They do pay.
Do you ever see what they do?
They stretch your bones where they
break them and then extend to,
do you know how crazy you have
to be to get your shins extended?
They cut your shins,
they saw into you and then they put this
metal brace all around you like a halo
brace,
and then you crank it
a little bit of click,
click,
because you have a couple inches taller.
Come on Bro.
For what?
So,
so it's an ego thing.
No.
So you can get laid.
I was watching this
documentary on Chinese guys.
This guy was like,
he had these braces on
his leg and he's like my,
my girlfriend,
she,
no,
she wouldn't marry me
because I'm too short,
but I'm going to come to her and I'm
going to be over five feet tall for the
first time to use it
under five feet tall kid.
Another girl.
Fuck that Hoe.
It's hard to get a girl
when you're four nine.
The biggest problem is
if you have a short deck.
Yeah.
But the biggest problem is if you're four,
nine D,
they don't wanna see your Dick.
Oh Jesus.
Look at this guy.
He went from five or to
say he getting six inches.
Five,
six to six foot.
Okay,
let me see this.
Oh God.
He was a thick,
he on the low gain,
six inches from stretching.
It's fucking bones out.
Let me see what it says there.
How unhappy do you have
to be with your body?
Go up there.
Nip Tuck,
grow.
Five foot,
six inch man underwent
astonishing leg length.
Any procedure because he
wanted to be six foot tall.
Oh,
he started at five six and he
got up to six feet tall us.
But how fucking damaging is that?
Well,
how we see the procedure in which both
legs are broken then slowly stretched
bears more than a little
resemblance to medieval torture.
Let me see what this fucking
guy did too is oh my God.
Oh my God.
It has to be some mental health issue.
Yeah.
Oh,
a little bit about the Trent.
Well,
maybe if you wanted to
really play football,
the trend for Ling Leong limb lengthening
surgery swept China where minimum
heights are often quoted on personal
adverts and job advertisement says the
country opened up to
the west a decade ago.
Look at that fucking thing on his leg,
man.
Oh my God.
So his,
we're looking at here,
it looks like they stick
cut an inch out of his bone,
but then they have this
bar that runs through it.
So that's his femur mad
dude that the IP leg bone,
that's not even his shin.
How do you think he's going to feel when
he's 70 that can't be good for what?
To be five inches taller to get a skill.
You know what chicks dig
over height skill man.
Funny.
Get a fucking ah,
650 leg lengthening
procedures in West Palm Beach,
Florida.
Not all to remedy deformity.
Some of them to remedy deformities.
Which makes sense.
Now how long do you think it takes for
them to fucking recover from something
like that?
A lifetime.
Oh,
they kind of height dysphoria.
So it's sorta like
Anorexia with their height.
It's a mental disorder.
Oh,
it's one of the few psychiatric disorders
that you can actually cure with the
knife says the surgeon.
Oof what?
US as the surgeon trying
to sell this bullshit.
Doctor uses the term night for you
don't really use it on a knife,
bro.
Don't you have a scalpel?
And I ain't going to that guy.
What I can cure.
What the saw it costs 85 grand.
Look what it says he does here.
It's 30 surgery is not
for the fainthearted.
The leg bone is broken into.
The doctor then implants a state of the
art telescopic rod into the cartilage of
the bone,
which then pulls it apart very gradually.
One millimeter a day.
New living bone grows along it to
fill the gap and muscles or in nerves.
The arteries is skin
also renew themselves.
The cost is prohibitive.
$85,000 takes at least
three months to complete.
Grueling physical therapy is essential.
Ah,
look at that one.
Look at the gap and it's fucking leg.
Look how big that gap you can play in
any slower walking up that kind of like
kicking him.
Yeah,
I was just thinking that.
Oh,
imagine if he decides to do Moitai.
I betcha his um,
like where your leg is
vulnerables changed,
right?
Dude,
if your girl geometry core leg is like,
if you,
if your leg is a certain,
like your bones are certain wit,
I
would imagine there's like a,
like it all make sense pretty
much in terms of like mathematics,
like how long your knee is
or how long your femur is.
It would be a certain thickness,
but then if you spread it out,
it's like the thickness of a shorter one.
But now it's long and
it's probably more safe.
Like stilt that make
me tell our community.
I just found,
oh wow.
There's a whole trick deduction to
leg lengthening and frequently asked
questions.
Holy Shit.
There's only 30 posts though,
dude,
that's just that.
Thank you.
This one's got 300 posts.
This is 3000 posts down here.
Diary on a ton though of a,
I'd be more worried about
lengthening those guys.
Is there a lengthening Dick Community?
Fuck yeah.
You know what they do?
They're all age.
They hang weights on how dare you.
What?
Racist?
No,
it's life.
It's got to be some Asians
with giant dogs out there.
I feel like we'd know about it.
Right?
Cause that,
yeah,
it'd be flaunting his shit.
Make me longer community then or make me
a bigger cock community because there's
death,
there's procedure you can
do like to cut it right?
Just Google.
How do I get a bigger cock?
So that's the thing.
[inaudible]
porn site.
There's the pumps because the pump
man you like if you everybody,
if it was something that really worked,
everybody would know about it.
Yeah.
Fuck you out there.
Would you want any room?
You walked in with a
bunch of dudes be like,
dude,
you see that new fucking device.
Get Your Dick Bigger.
Everybody.
Once he devices and Dick's,
those two words don't go
together like a device.
I think I'm like clamps and screws.
If you ever seen a penis
place like from Austin Powers,
I've seen one.
I've never seen one in person like being
used like with a blown up Dickinson.
I've never seen it being used,
but I've seen one in person and it's very,
I mean it's intense dude.
I've heard that some guys
like especially old fellows,
they use one.
Then penis pumps to just get hard ons.
Oh yeah.
That it's attached to them.
No,
they,
they have that too.
Like that was in Liberace and the um,
Candelabra Oh I love that movie when we
sell getting his bag and Matt Damon 24,
seven,
I think it was like how do you stay hard?
Oh that's right.
Got An implant.
That's right.
Yeah.
Do that movie so good.
That's a crazy movie man.
That'd be a weird movie to
make if you're Matt Damon.
Cause they're like,
he talks about it too.
There's a scene where,
spoiler,
there's a scene where he's in a speedo
and Michael Douglas is just like laying
down in the pool and he has
straddles him and just full on,
ah,
just,
you know,
Matt Damon Straight as shit
to playing the character.
That'd be tough though.
Like if Hollywood came to me was like,
Brennan,
we need you to play the new Batman,
but you got to go add it with
the joker mouth to mouth.
And you guys are bumpy is in the movie.
Yeah.
You'd be like,
yeah,
it'd be a little bit of a struggle.
That's a hard pass.
But how much you say,
do you think you could live
in Las Vegas like that?
Do you think you'd do a
residency in Las Vegas?
No.
Like it would if they offered you the,
the,
the big brown boom boom room,
boom,
boom.
Like a fucking,
what is it at Mandalay bay.
Like Jay Leno type of shit
getting 30 million a year.
Yeah,
something crazy like that.
Like a Britney Spears type deal?
I don't think so.
I,
I'm,
and this is different for me.
I have such a,
a stressful connotation when it goes,
comes to Vegas,
cause a fighting.
It's whenever I think of
things I think of stress,
stress,
stress.
So as soon as I land in Vegas I get all
introverted and I searched sweating.
It's just not because I've
done so much work there.
I was on the ultimate fighter
there for eight weeks,
you know,
I've had some huge fights there.
So for me when I think of Vegas,
I think of k like stressful,
stressful,
Don Jr.
Yeah.
So it'd be tough for me to live there for,
that'd be really tough.
It goes,
people do residency for like two years.
Could you do it?
I don't know.
Um,
I don't think I could.
Well I think the thing about Vegas
is you got to not live in Vegas.
Like you don't want to have like a,
a suite at Mandalay bay
or something like that.
I think the move is to live in like
Henderson or something like that.
Like by red rocks or,
yeah,
one of those places.
And you just drive in.
I think that's the move.
Cause then you're just living in a town,
well not even a big town.
See,
I would say fuck all that noise.
And I probably,
if they offered me 30 million,
I'd probably hire a bill burr fucking
helicopter pilot type of dude.
And I'd live in La and just
fly out there on Fridays.
I think it's a long flight.
No helicopter doesn't toss to
something like that are used to it.
When he was going there,
he would just flying in for
like Friday night on a plane.
That 25 minute flight.
It is.
What,
was he doing that a lot?
Yeah,
he was,
he was for awhile.
Right Saturday or something like that.
They might stay the night,
but they'd be back within 36
hours or something like that.
I can,
I cannot live there,
man.
There's no way just because of your past
experience that and just in general.
It's just not for me.
It's not my type of living cause or a,
Ralphie may had a residency there
for awhile and he was doing it,
but that's where he died.
I know Eddie Griffin has a residency.
Dice had a residency there for awhile to,
Seinfeld did too.
I think he said he'll does.
Yeah,
he was making films.
Yeah.
Really?
It's just,
there's a lot of great stuff there,
right?
Like what do you like to do?
Do you like to go to restaurants?
Great restaurants.
What do you like to do?
Do you like to go to the movie
theater and there's plenty of movies.
Great shows.
Yeah,
there's plenty of gyms,
amazing places to work out.
There's a lot of stuff there.
I just,
I don't know man.
I know,
I know what,
that's what I'm saying.
It's like sweat and talking about,
I don't know what it is.
I just,
I guess I have some great friends who
live in Vegas and some of the best people
I know live in Vegas.
Some of the best people I
know work in the night clubs.
You know what we need to do?
We need to sit down before big events
and make a youtube video where we're just
breaking down each event,
like fight by fight as it comes up.
I think people would really enjoy that.
But you and me breaking down the,
the big fight.
Yeah,
breaking down big events,
you know?
Good idea.
Like if,
if I didn't work for the UFC,
I would love to go there and just like
cover the weigh ins as like a spectator
but as as unfiltered no production
and me just talking shit.
Yes.
Like I don't like doing
the weigh ins stressful.
I try to pronounce people's names,
Peel Troy young,
like what the,
they're going to be a worst job for me.
If you ask me to pronounce
everyone's names correctly,
some of these Russian cats,
they're names are off the charts and
it starts with the Russian g and a z.
But you got to use a why not for me.
It like a why,
like what not for me.
What is the name?
Yeah.
I have to write it out phonetically.
How much longer you think you'd do that?
I don't know.
Just between me and you.
No one's listening.
I don't know.
I do enjoy her.
Thought about it.
Yes,
all the time.
The guy cut way back cause first of
all I was doing too many of them at one
point in time I was doing 24 a year.
It was way too many.
It was like half the year.
I was half the weekends in the year I
was flying somewhere to go to the UFC.
But that's when you did
international as well?
Yeah,
it was too much.
And that was before the UFC really?
Um,
they started adding a bunch of people and
it took a lot of the weight off of me.
Yeah,
I'm sad they got rid of Jimmy Smith.
I think Jimmy Smith is really good.
I think he's really good.
But sometimes it's just not a fit.
Like I didn't see,
I didn't find him.
And maybe he didn't get his fair shot.
I think he's one of the
best companies in the world,
but it never felt right.
Maybe because he was at,
he didn't get to do it enough.
He's brilliant at his job,
but there was the,
I just didn't,
it never felt right to me.
It was like watching Joe
Montana played for the chiefs.
Well,
I'm selfish.
He's my friend.
I was happy he was there.
I think he's really good.
I love Jimmy.
I'm not saying,
I think he's great.
I think he's gonna gone.
Whoever finds them,
it can be lucky,
but it never,
like the writing was on the wall because
you would see DC who's amazing and I
see Paul Felder who was
amazed that Dominick Cruz,
Michael Bisbing.
It's like,
well of course Jimmy's
not going to have a job.
Like they're going to
use the in house guys.
That's the direction they're going.
Yeah,
I guess so.
I wonder if he could do play by play.
You know,
like when the ones in antique doesn't
want to do and it does and it does all
the,
hey Anik,
go home to your kids.
Don't you have like seven daughters,
dude,
go home to your fucking kids.
John knows I love him,
but I see him at Brazil and
a post like two days sleep,
you know,
been on the road 19 days in a row.
I'm like,
dude,
go home bro.
He can't,
he's,
he's the best.
He's really good.
There's not a better commentating team
in the history of combat sports when it's
you DC and Jon Anik,
that's the best.
It's fun.
It's a fun DC's himself and he's one
of the best fighters of all time.
Genetics.
Very fucking good.
He's a brilliant dude.
And then you do your thing and that's,
he's a dcs so loose too.
Like he makes it silly.
He's a special dude.
Like when,
uh,
when rose knocked out a Yoni
and Jay Jackie's like thug rose,
what you want thug rose,
you can't,
you can't pay for that.
That's natural that you either got it.
He don't,
and he hasn't yet.
That's his future man.
Yeah.
At this future.
Well that's why everybody
kind of wants him to retire.
You know?
That's why I think his family is kind
of pushing for him to retire and I talk
crazy.
Bob Cook,
he's like,
I'd be happy for retired right now.
I,
and I don't think the UFC is going to
let him retire without facing judgment,
the heavyweight division.
And he certainly can retire if he
decides to [inaudible] not happening.
You don't think so?
Nope.
They're gonna throw that big cause we
sit down and you sit down and make a deal
with the devil.
That Ikea thing about retiring.
Very cool.
Here's the thing,
we're going to pay you this
much to fight this monster.
They're going to get out that Pantego.
Yup.
And then got to push
that a piece of paper.
Crossing's going to
have a theme every time.
What does it look?
Do me a favor.
Just look at this Red
Strip steak house in Vegas.
We're talking about 2 million pay per
view buys and this is what you would get
separate life.
He's probably set for life already.
Ah,
he made $4 million with Derek Lewis.
They are not sad.
I don't think you're set with email.
Who knows how much you made
for Steve Bay who won't?
Who knows how much he made.
I mean,
in a way,
let's say after taxes,
10 million in the bank is
that sat not how to live.
We let go and watch kit out.
You weren't a gold watch,
bro.
Dude,
that's not that crazy.
CK has a joke and his,
uh,
his newest set about finding a cold water,
they say solid.
It wasn't doing the same.
Couldn't be more opposite.
Yeah.
You got a gold watch.
Gold Watch dog.
It's a gold Rolex.
The fucking Gold Rolex man.
See,
that's what I'm saying.
$10 million isn't going to last for
you to 10 million would last room.
I'm not that crazy.
Everyone thinks I'm crazy.
How long would it last
for the rest of your life?
Do you tell me that I'd be
set with my investments,
stuff like that.
Buy Property.
I'd be,
I'd be panicking.
Count,
well,
don't get me wrong,
I wouldn't stop working.
You know what I'm saying?
But if you wanted to stop working,
if you wanted to,
I don't know.
Have you ever thought about,
have you ever put a number
where if I get here,
I can chill out and
like I don't need to do,
I have 17 podcast,
I don't need to do all that word.
I don't need to do nine sets of week at,
you know,
the comedy store and get good.
I know,
but what if I want to get 100% if only
he'd get up podcasts and do that if I
want to get good at.
But there has to be some material
level financially where I can get to.
I can,
I can chill out on this,
but I'm not,
I'm not,
I'm not built that way.
Every morning I wake up like off,
fuck man,
we ready to get going.
I better get going.
I don't,
um,
I don't think about retiring
because I like what I do.
So I don't think,
I don't think like,
oh,
I need to have x amount of money in the
bank so I'm not going to do this very
much longer.
I'm not saying retiring,
I'm saying maybe cut back
on all the shit you do.
Like all that stuff.
I think it keeps me from going crazy to
think being active keeps me from losing
my marbles just around the house.
Just only with my demons.
Depressed.
I don't think I'd ever get depressed.
No.
I get depressed if I'm not,
if I'm not busy,
if I'm with my son,
I'm good,
but you leave me alone now I'm
like a Gremlin after midnight.
Don't leave me alone man.
I don't like being all
by myself all the time.
Well,
I have so many different
interests that have the sort of,
one of the patterns that I've picked
up my whole life is that I like to do.
I find things that I like to do
when I do them as much as I can.
I would,
I mean I have so many different things,
whether it's archery or
martial arts or I would,
I've joined the fucking pro pool tour.
I would do some see,
but everything your timeout,
it would you wouldn't hear good about
too though is you're doing that with
friends like so your friends are the
best in the world at those things.
You just mentioned that his
hand in that helps having,
well yeah,
if you were alone with no friends,
that shit is very,
that's what I can get a little dark if
you leave me like my brother goes on the
road to me all the time it up then tons
of dates and when he's not with me and
I'm in that room all by myself
for like three or four days,
like,
oh,
I'm not,
I'm not happy man.
I'm not doing well.
I don't know.
I tried something I need to talk
someone about but I don't know.
That is a depressing thing when
you were alone on the road.
Um,
I used to do those gigs on the road
with no opening act like way back in the
day.
That's when I'll do work with a local guy.
And it was just not,
if the local guy was cool,
it was great.
We had a good old time and it was fun.
I hope it,
uh,
and you know,
I'm,
I,
I like everybody,
but if,
if I'm all set,
I'm friends.
So if you're not in my group,
I don't want to spend time like I'm
not going to go to eat with you.
I'm like,
I'll see you at sea at the venue man.
Like I don't want to
get to know each other.
I want to get to know anybody now.
No,
not really.
Your book's closed.
It's a lot of energy,
man.
You know I talked to her living.
So if you didn't have to work ever again,
what would you do with your time?
Like what if,
say you know,
you,
you hit the lottery,
you won $500 billion,
you never have to work again.
I would still do standup in podcasting.
Really guaranteed.
Yeah.
If I'm not busy,
like I like being stupid busy.
Like I didn't like,
you know,
Theo and I have a new podcast.
I didn't need to do that and
I have my show on showtime.
But yet you did need to do
that because I love doing it.
Well it's not for financial works good.
Like I love Theo by himself.
Like his podcast by
himself was really good.
Be here,
he's better with other people.
Yes.
Cause it's because other
people get to respond.
How ridiculous he is.
So out of this world it guess
half the fun is people go,
what the fuck are you talking some
crazy shit at some crazy shit mean.
You know,
me and him talked about doing it but
for a long time doing the king of this
thing a long time.
Then we even made the announcement
and then months later,
like even months later,
just because you know he's a busy guy.
I'm a busy guy and it's like
we don't need to do this.
Are you the sting?
He's the cause he called me,
he says,
I look all you get stung by a
bunch of bs cause I'm like swollen.
And I called him,
I said,
it looks like he,
you know,
keeps rats or something like that.
So I'll come the rat king and then just
stuck and then king in the sting and
it's been going great man.
It's been going great.
It's,
it's so different than
what Callen and I do.
And people are like,
oh fire the kid.
It's coming to an end.
No,
it's fucking not.
Come on.
Foreign kids.
Never been bigger,
man.
He can't pay attention every month.
It's built to build.
I don't know why,
but every month builds,
builds,
builds mean cal.
I'm doing great,
but there's the rat king.
That's what he looks like.
This is a turtles.
Oh Dude.
We have a,
we have a segment on the show called
flaunt my aunt and people send in pictures
of their aunts and we wrote to him,
you don't show the picture online.
Do we?
Sure do serve people.
It's not all bad things like some,
some girl set a picture of uh,
her uncle and she's like,
Yo,
talk about my uncle.
So you know,
if he always tries to be positive and I
take it down a weird road but it's great
or so and send a picture of
their APP from the 1950s,
she got pretty hot.
Uh,
our producer Chin showed his aunt,
aunt and she was hot as fuck.
1950s hot was different.
Black and white,
mushy.
There we are talking about
somebody who's fucking,
and then someone's old on 75 years old,
you guys have a nice set.
Where's your set?
Is it then the same complex where
you do a fighter and the kid?
No,
so it's a,
it's in Santa Monica and um,
it's,
it's um,
the company that produced called Ma
Malka and they do all my showtime stuff.
So showtime with Brian
Dailey and those guys,
they went,
we want to make it as easy as possible
because you have all these shows,
we don't want you driving all over.
So they just had a very much
smaller scale in this base.
He did like a Joe Rogan style where they
built me set where it's kind of like my
fantasy land.
So I'll have all my below the showtime
stuff there of King of the sting there.
What's with the bumblebee colors?
That Charlie Brown colors?
I don't know.
We have a set designer there.
I'm like,
all right,
well we're not huge Charlie band fans.
It's too on the nose.
Black and yellow.
It's like a bee sting.
I used a little way.
It's too on the nose.
Uh,
see it's 200.
You know what I'm saying?
It's very fashion conscious though.
I'll do that stuff.
It drives me nuts.
I was going to say last night
you were and you trust out,
man.
I dressed up.
You like panel shark and fly you Peter.
Look for DCF.
Jamie looked pretty dope.
You're on stage.
I looked at,
Brian said,
it's fuck.
Look at Rogin with the swaggy tonight.
It's drip,
drip sound.
Wonderful trip.
It was good.
Like damn look good dude.
Those friends dress horrible dude.
They uh theos the worst dressed person.
I know Brian.
Theo.
Where's like those pants with like rubber
bands on the bottom of like parachute
pants?
Like their mom vegan pants.
They're very,
he wears Veekan pack.
What does that mean?
Did you,
there's just some bullshit pants.
Like where's those me too moment pants.
Like they're just so non Alpha Male,
you know,
like that's just what he wears.
That's his style.
They taper down the bottom
and then there's elastic
that holds them up like six
inches away from his shoe.
It's very yoga mom ish.
And then,
then he wears weird shoes and then he'll
wear like Nike shoes with Reebok socks.
Drives me fucking nuts.
That drives me nuts.
Really nuts dude.
I did that the other day.
No,
you did it as I did have a pair of
converse with a pair of Adidas a and I was
thinking about it before I left
him like no one's gonna know.
Oh,
if I,
Dude Jamie,
you come with the same like if I,
if you did that at my school,
you wouldn't have got out
alive by fifth period.
There's a word for it.
Mismatched PR purpose maybe.
I don't know.
There's like,
there's like a word when you were,
when you found that it was like an
early nineties thing I remember on it.
Yeah.
It just wasn't my thing.
Um,
yeah,
but it's,
it's a good time.
It didn't,
what Fiona,
Fiona and I tried to do is
something completely different.
There's,
there's,
it's not like open ended conversation.
There's no guests.
It's just,
it's all segments king adjusting
it and it's all fancy emissions.
So people are viewing videos.
Go Yo,
Burger King or Mcdonald's.
I mean him debate Mcdonald's,
Burger King or flunk
mine sending pictures.
Here you have a preference to
burger king and Mcdonald's.
I'm a Burger King Guy.
A whopper with cheese.
Well,
I didn't say either one is healthy,
but they're fucking,
he's like,
Shit.
Doing a whopper with cheese.
What do you like fast food?
You have to choose between Wendy's and
Burger King right next to each other.
King all day.
Whopper with cheese.
Ketchup only bro.
That's outrageous.
You went Wendy's.
Of course,
dude.
They're square patties you isis funds
which shapes the square patties.
What's my script?
Pizza tour.
It's slices.
Give a fuck.
As long as it tastes good dude.
Not worried about shapes.
Come on Bro.
You're so fashion conscious that drives
me that you should have been a gay guy
in another life to Pri.
Yeah,
like if I get,
that's why I stopped fighting.
Drain a second straightness
fashion conscious guy.
I know I,
yeah,
I don't know why.
Like you're really into like looks
and fashion and trends and stuff.
Yeah.
You pay attention.
The only guy that I know that does that,
I've had my outfit picked out for my
special Saturday for three weeks now.
Wow.
I went through like constantly thinking,
constantly thinking,
what am I going to do?
You should have a tiger come out in a
cage like Katt Williams were the top.
Yeah.
Just to go nuts and have a fur coat and
has some chicks take the fur coat off
when you get on stage.
The set's a little outrageous,
crazy set.
Not Crazy,
but I'm like,
oh,
that's very,
it's very Kevin Hart hedge.
Like that's when they sit there.
They,
all right.
Well that's,
that'll work.
Yeah.
Excited.
I can't wait man.
That's fucking awesome.
I've never been more excited.
So the same night that you are doing
your showtime Special Tj Dillashaw is
fighting Henry's Hutto.
Who else is on that card?
Pull that card up.
Good card man.
First card ever for ESPN plus ESPN plus.
So it's a streaming thing.
You watch
cowboy a Serone though
on the unregular ESPN.
He's the,
he's the main amount of
the regular ESPN then.
So it's weird because the prelims
are on the digital device.
Then it goes regular,
uh,
ESPN for the Donald Cerrone fight.
Then you got switched back to the digital.
It can take a little while for
people to get used to that.
Some people are super bummed out
with my friend Brian Stevens.
He lives in a rural Texas outside of
Dallas and he's bummed out because his
internet something that fast.
It's like,
you know,
in certain places you can't get fax,
Internet,
Frilly,
2019 he can't get Wifi.
If you want to live on a ranch,
the whole live on a fucking rant.
You going have to get slowly ranch.
Fuck Bro.
No,
there's some stuff they can do some stuff,
right.
Well,
you can,
if you really want to be,
you know,
balling,
you got to spend a lot of money.
Like it took four months for us to
get legit internet at the old place.
They had a chew up the streets and we're,
you know,
we were in,
the Canoga Park area,
which has all these businesses
and they legit there.
Yeah.
They,
it's a fucking,
it's a grind to get legit
internet in some spots.
Oh boy.
Can't get it.
So he's bummed out it.
Yeah.
So He's,
you know,
they used to be able to watch all
the good fights on a regular TV.
So here we go.
Um,
Greggor Gillespie versus Yancey Madeiros.
Grego Gillespie is that
guy's a fucking beast.
Minus five 50.
You look at it.
Yeah,
he's us.
Darryl's whelming favorite look
that could be fight of the night.
I love how you skip over the Greg Hardy.
We all recognize this bullshit
and then let's keep going.
Is it bullshit?
I mean,
the guy's got fucking serious power.
Well,
the only thing that does he,
he's fought cans.
He said No.
So on the ESPS,
far cans to co main event.
Well,
he's deaf.
it's because of his name.
He's dead.
Well,
Allen Crowder,
I don't know him.
I don't know who,
who?
Alan Crowder's and he's Greg Allen.
Giant favorite 600.
Yeah,
he's a minus 600.
The wait a minute.
He calls himself the prince of war.
Hey Bro.
Whoa.
No,
he doesn't it.
Yes he does.
Greg,
the print of war hardy.
Wow.
Don't do that.
Do not.
Absolutely.
Do not do that.
Do that.
Decent nicknames are so bad.
Like someone needs like a nickname coach.
The UFC should provide,
you know how they have like the athletes,
the performance center,
the athletes get to go center.
Yeah.
They have a niche to have a nickname
center like Greg or the Gift Gillespie.
That's a good name dude.
All the triple cheese.
That mother fucker can wrestle.
Holy Shit.
And he ran fish too.
He can fight.
Yeah.
He's a good freshman.
So fucking serious wrestler though.
This is a good fight.
Does for veto is a good fight.
Yeah.
Did they did fight before and um,
Benevidez one right?
Yeah.
Bellevue as a motherfucker.
Love Benevidez glow over
to share and call Roberson.
That's a good fight.
Carl Robertson is a fucking beast man.
Interesting nicknames.
He say Robertson.
Robertson.
Carl Baby.
K Robertson.
Yeah.
That mother fucker can fight.
He is good.
Striking.
Very good.
Yeah.
He hurt his foot in his last fight,
like early on.
But this is a big step up for him.
It's getting a little long in the tooth,
a lot long in the tooth,
but he's still tough as shit.
If that goes to the ground,
you could get dicey.
And then the next one,
boys get your dates out.
Van Zandt doing Rachel almost of itch.
Dimey demis of all diabetes.
They're better looking
than the green card girls.
Well most of which has the most rid
donkey body and her face is re she's
beautiful too.
Time.
She's so beautiful.
Her body is so ridiculous.
It's like are you are person?
Yeah.
At risk at all for that girl.
Um,
and then you got,
he got Paige vanzant who's,
why does it seem one 55
she's not willing to fund.
That's a title on UFC guys.
Get your fucking people on the website.
Tam.
It,
someone's an asshole.
They want to make fun of her.
She just won 55.
They could also do a
better picture of him.
Girl who works for the w,
the girlfriend of the web designers
ways one 55 slash 45 but she 55
she uh,
yeah.
She's easy on the eyes too.
Yeah,
she's beautiful.
they're both gorgeous women.
It's crazy though that most of it's coming
off of that domestic violence thing.
Where have you seen the video of that?
No disturbance.
It's her husband saying
he's gonna kill her.
It's super disturbing
and if you need security,
Rachel,
I am here for you.
So sad.
Um,
they have kids together too.
It's just so fucked up.
It's super dark.
But to put her on the
card with Greg Hardy,
there was a giant,
a lot of people criticizing that
in the UFC does not give a fuck.
Well,
the thing is that Greg
Hardy was on the card.
The card was set before she
got assaulted by her husband,
so it was already in place.
She was supposed to be on the car.
They pulled her from the card when they
thought that she had a broken orbital
bone.
She went to a different doctor.
I guess she got some actual
exams and Mris and stuff.
Turns out she didn't have
a broken orbital bone.
They cleared it a fight.
She begged them to let her
fight because she just,
she doesn't want this to take her out
of fighting is what meets a gigantic
catastrophe,
a horrible dilemma in her life.
It's hard not to root for
her husband hits her Pizza,
rob.
It's awful.
And she's like,
I'm not gonna let this Guy Stop my career.
I'm not going to let this
guy changed the path.
My life.
I'm done with him.
I want to fight.
And she begged them to let
her fight and I'm just saying,
if I'm the UFC,
I go,
all right,
Greg Hardy,
he's not a big draw.
He's not,
he's not a veteran.
There's nothing going on here.
Let's just move them to any
other fucking card we have.
We're sensitive to this.
We don't Hae,
no one's tuned in.
Just one.
It's not a big deal.
Moving to the next call.
I think they want some controversy.
I think they like controversy.
I think any sort of press and they live
and die by this negative press is good
press.
We'll look at what the John Joe's thing,
they don't give a fuck Conor Khabib thing.
They kept showing him throwing the,
the,
the Dolly at the bus.
They kept showing it over and over again.
Promos until they're appointed.
You know,
it kind of works.
Fuck cad work.
That was at Joe you and paper view.
I mean that was just,
it works.
So he can't,
yeah.
This one's a little different.
Like throwing a Dolly through the window
when with other professional fighters.
All right.
Whatever.
I botched that.
I hyped that shit too with this one.
I can't,
I just can't.
I'm out.
I'm not hyping it.
I can't get on board for it.
Well,
it's not like Austin,
which is fighting her
boyfriend or husband.
It'd be cool.
She was,
I think he's a fighter
that can be troublesome.
Looks pretty jagged.
Yeah,
that's true.
Not Good.
The whole thing is so ugly.
It's tough.
What are the fights?
What are the fights are cowboy.
Alexander Hernandez is a fucking beast.
That is a good fight.
That guy is super cocky to
Alexander the Great Hernandez.
He is a bad motherfucker.
Cowboy being cowboy.
Just taking a random ass fight.
Yeah.
Well this is his first.
This is Hernandez.
His first fight in the big leagues.
Um,
let me look at his record.
They show his record.
No,
but I mean look at it.
The actual fights,
this show who he's fought,
they don't have that on the web.
He hasn't fought anyone.
Nowhere on your account.
On the website.
I'm on the fight card,
I don't believe,
but maybe on here guy here on his page.
They do.
Wow.
How weird.
I mean,
he'd be where you shot a dowel merciay.
How dare you.
She's a motherfucker and he not,
he starts to him.
Yeah.
He starts Dariusz and he beat Obama.
Rca.
Those are two really good fighters.
Yeah.
But the way he beat dairy,
which I was like,
Holy Shit,
he's fast as fuck.
He's got serious power.
He's really technical too.
And he's really hungry.
Like he,
he views his cowboy fight as
the breakout opportunities.
A young line man.
Yeah,
he's,
yeah.
He's got real future
championship potential.
He's one of those guys.
You look at,
you go,
let's see,
let's do this.
Just shows with cowboy.
It's just like,
um,
make zero sense in the world.
But Kevin,
I just want to stay active.
He's a savage man.
He just loves it.
And you know what,
man,
I mean,
if you look at his last
fight against Perry,
he's still fighting smooth and smart.
He looked fantastic in that fight.
Good short work.
A Peri Peri is a dangerous guy.
Powerful guy.
Cowboy.
You're going to cowboy man.
It's very interesting.
Very interesting.
Fine.
I'm,
that might be one of the fights
that I'm most curious about.
For sure.
Yeah.
That mother Fucker,
you just go down the first kid and I've
seen this kid since he walked in the gym
at 13.
Cory,
Sandy Hagan.
He came into Aurora high altitude when
I was fighting and he was a basketball
player in high school and came in
there and he is a mother fucker.
He is damn good.
He switched fight John Linacre.
But John got hurt,
but he,
until this kid is stand
up by super special,
five 11,
one 35.
That's a tall gentleman
for that weight class.
He's a protege of Christian Allen.
He,
this kid has skills,
man.
Damn.
I don't know.
I don't,
I know nothing about Mario Amputees.
I have nothing about,
see if you can find a video of
Corey Fighting Corey San Hagen,
uh,
just his movement.
You'll see how fluid is movement is in
how an orthodoxy is and he's good in all
he is.
The one downfall might be his wrestling,
but he's fucking good man.
Yeah.
It's a fun time right now
for for up and coming talent.
There's so many cutbacks
as far as combat sports,
including boxing and MMA.
They're going to,
in the business we're in,
they couldn't be a better time.
I know,
right?
It's crazy.
It's a,
it's a male soap opera.
I always have something to talk about.
The only thing that's
left out is kickboxing.
Kickboxing still is not
getting any traction.
You know what?
It's just like Jujitsu,
like it's never going to just blow up
like these other sports because it's,
it's the way the world is.
Joe.
No one gives a fuck.
Yeah.
That's the one thing that I think is
missing is kickboxing blowing up the,
again,
I love combat sports,
but it's like I'm not going to jump to
my couch to watch kickbox and origins too
and I love Jujitsu,
but I'm not going to like if
it was a big kick boxing card,
like I watched Overeem Bahari didn't we
go to see Joe Schilling fight together?
Did you come with me to that event?
I didn't go with you can go with that.
All tweaking of that.
Uh,
coker text me last night.
I didn't get back to
them so I just got fader.
Yeah.
He's like,
Dude,
you Lynn for fader Bader.
Get back to me yet either.
I was going to ask you.
Yeah,
I was waiting.
He wants to go.
Should we go?
Is it next weekend?
Is the 26th,
the weekend after your uh,
your event?
It's at the forum.
That can be fun.
We should go to see fade or fight.
Lie Too.
Cause if,
especially if he loses
plenty of the last time,
well it's just that the opportunity to
see if there's five all time greatest
fighters in history.
He's on that list.
Have you been to a live feed or never?
I've been to two when,
when he fought Ronnie Coleman a Vegas
and when he fell and then I worked at the
bell tower when he fought a mitre own.
Here's San Hagen,
get a change.
God,
he's so tall for 35.
He looks like a Vegan that like cl smooth.
He is,
when he switches,
he got lit up there.
And this,
but uh,
he,
he's very smooth man.
Oh,
he fought Uri Alcantara.
That's a tough one.
Woo.
Jesus.
All this.
This is one of the rounds of the year.
He gets in trouble and you think
you submitted his snack in his arm.
He goes on to win this fight.
I'm pretty sure Jesus Christ.
Oh my God.
How does he not tap here?
This is crazy.
He's triangled.
He's in a full on armbar humans.
Guinea.
His arm fucked up.
He gets out of this.
Oh my God.
How's he get out of this?
I have no idea what heart.
Yeah,
here's a special talent.
Oh my God.
He's got some rubber arms.
Look at his arm.
His arm looks broken,
man.
He's broken.
Look at it.
Look how far it's bent back.
And I'm surprised the reference stuff.
Oh,
I'm surprised the ref didn't stop though.
Oh No,
no.
It's turned sideways now.
See the way his wrist is,
Yup.
That's actually going with the
joint because he's doing this now,
so he's actually in way better shape.
Nannies bleeding.
Now he's fucked.
Oh No.
But he bent it down.
Dude.
He's safe.
He's actually,
he's actually doing his
shirt and not doing well.
Defense.
Well,
shoulders,
not in danger there.
He's doing very good with defense.
Look,
he's getting cut up from this.
This is incredible.
Yeah,
it controls the leg so he can escape.
Oh my God,
this is horrific to watch.
How does he get out of this?
That's incredible.
How can has got to be like,
what the fuck is that guy not
to break your will when you,
when you do all that and he's still
there and they look at him and then he's
smashing you and then you're
tired and you realize like,
oh my God,
I should,
I tried to choke him.
He should've committed to the triangle.
I mean the triangle is fully locked in
through that permitting to alarm or with
nasty.
It was nasty,
but triangles put you to sleep.
The thing about armbars is
you can let your arm snap.
You really can and guys have,
there's some crazy savage is out there
that will let you break their arm.
No time they stop at,
but when you get put to sleep,
you get put to sleep,
get your triangle better,
be fucking good.
Especially this [inaudible] triangle
besides fucking by our Tayga,
like the triangle.
Better be God damn good man.
Guys are so good with their
defense with triangles these days.
Yeah,
and triangles aren't,
you know,
Cory's a black belt,
right?
But it's like,
who's who's,
uh,
who's triangle is that good?
Like triangle defense
or trial submissions?
Charles Fortune's by the best in the UFC.
Yeah.
T city to city.
That's what it stands for.
If people,
you know,
people have seen him in
the Max Holloway fight.
If you've only seen him
fighting that fight,
God,
you go back and watch him do your
homework is submissions are so nasty.
It's flying triangles.
San Hagans is hoggin sand hog and
or San Hagen and Sienna Hagen.
San Hagen is just smashing down on them.
I'll can taros seemed spent again,
came to the gym basketball player.
No experience.
That's zero at 13 young.
You ever see the 13 year olds learn shit
stink about 13 walk in the gym and you
have this work ethic from
basketball and you're like,
oh,
I'll try this stuff out.
And you walk in the gym,
you got Christian Allen who's a Ninja
and then he just downloads all his
experience into like,
all right,
then you're in the fucking UFC.
Amazing.
That is.
And he was gonna be an underdog against
John Linacre and he would have beat
Linacre man.
Dude,
he's some mash in Alcantara.
How does this fight end?
Do you remember?
Uh,
Corey wins.
He's beaten up
a bonus for that night.
You will think Alcantara
is probably after all that.
He's like,
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
he's not even defending himself.
Well,
he's exhausted from,
but he's like trying to block the damn
shoulder the way he's defending himself.
Like,
look at it the way he's,
what he's doing.
It's almost like he's confused that the
guy is still there and he's pounding on
him now.
He's like letting him
know he must be exhausted.
He emptied his gas tank
up.
Yeah,
he's getting fucked up,
dude.
Hop Out.
So like you can move right now.
He's so exhausted man.
I'm for that.
Nogueira sweep the deep half.
Yup.
Knowing better.
Um,
yeah man.
That's it.
That's interesting.
And,
and that is on,
what is that on fight pass?
Some of them are at file pass.
Oh No.
Fight Pass.
That's a,
this is on ESPN plus.
Okay.
So goes ESPN plus then he had jumped
a regular ESPN to watch cowboy.
Then you got to get jumped back to the
digital platform to watch the rest of the
card.
Why?
Terrible idea.
Whoever did that really terrible idea.
Really terrible ideas back and forth.
Yeah.
That doesn't make,
is it not on an APP though?
ESPN APP saying it goes,
it goes APP regular TV to watch cop.
Like you can watch ESPN normal on the APP,
I believe.
I'm not sure where I'm at.
That's what I'm asking.
Well I'm not sure.
I hope hope Luke Thomas
was talking about it.
And so can you get the
APP on your television?
Could you do it through apple TV?
Should be,
yeah.
So you can just watch all of it.
Yeah.
Have you seen the Oh,
so at the end he stopped him.
Yup.
Damn crazy dude.
Hop Out.
Fucking Cain Velasquez first.
Francis in Ghana.
Ooh,
that makes me nervous.
For who?
For Cane.
Really?
Yeah.
It's amazing.
Fight for cane.
It's a great fight for cane.
If he gets that guy to the ground,
it's a great fight for Francis
to what makes me excited.
I mean,
I say nervous anytime
I see Francis fighting,
I'm nervous for his opponent because he,
I wasn't nervous after the steep a fight.
I was like half fuck.
You weren't nervous in
the Derrick Lewis fight?
No.
I thought if he thought the way he
always fights that would be a car Raisie
fight.
But he was so nervous from that fight
from the steep bay fight that he just
dealing terrible.
He just couldn't pull the trigger.
Well then it was Derrick
rose had a hurt back.
So you've got a complete shit
show out of two knockout artists.
I just think that,
um,
that,
uh,
you know,
Keynes been out for a long time.
He's a motherfucker though.
Oh,
he's the best,
I think is the best.
I think he's the best in terms
of like physical ability.
You think he's the best
heavyweight of all time?
I think he's amassed.
I think he has to do I
to do a little more work.
I think he's the best in terms
of what he's accomplished.
I think [inaudible] is the
best heavyweight of all
time in terms of what he's
accomplished.
Maybe maybe you can make the argument for,
for BC over doom because
boardroom beat him,
but I think for doom beat a fade or that
had already been through the ringer and
pride and you know the
all the chaos there.
I mean
he had been in those wars
with fucking cro cop,
but if you're doing beat him when it was
still the ORIF fade or here's the first
one where,
where you realized she's,
she knows,
cause Brett Rogers kind of
took a little bit out of that.
Did he starched fucking payout him?
But before that he had trouble with them.
It was a,
it wasn't an easy fight.
It wasn't an easy fight
and blazing respect Brat.
Right.
He did have a cro cop like
I mean you'll curl hop,
fucking punch and leaped and Oh fucking
God don't with that right hand and right
hand was ridiculous though.
I it's,
it's,
it's tough to say grace while time cause
it's the greatest of that time period.
Cause when,
when he was doing it,
there were specialists that he was great.
There were certain things
that made him great.
He was under size.
Cause if you put his skillset
with his frame now into the,
the,
the pool,
it's,
I don't know if he's the best,
but then Cain at his time when there's
jds and he's in his prime Brock Lesnar
and he's beating those guys,
what cane would do to people,
he would overwhelm you in a way
that looked like you were drowning.
His Cardio in and pace was insane.
Insane.
Like did you,
did junior dos Santos fights I
think took so much out of junior,
both of them.
I think it took it,
both of them paid the price it,
yeah,
it was the same thing as a,
I was listening to,
um,
who's the box you just had on from
a young staff love Kelly Patrick,
how are you saying he doesn't want you
to rematch with Canelo triple g cause it
takes so much out of those guys
that they're never the same.
I'm using,
I'm usually on the same thinking path.
Is that where I'm like,
God,
if those guys go at it again,
man,
we're never going to get a good product.
But Cain,
Cain and junior for sure.
I mean especially the third fight and
the third fight was second one to the
second one to pop both of them.
They just jds a steep bay.
Yeah.
That was,
that was very steep and jds
has had some Warthen steep.
It has had some wars and you can,
you can tell that they're there.
They're just different in life.
I'm not saying it's brain
train on whatever is,
but it's just,
they're just different.
They're not,
they leave a piece of themselves in that,
in that octagon.
Well,
it's for sure some brain trauma.
Yeah.
I'm just trying to be nice to try and
be nice and getting hit in the head that
much like they,
they leave,
they leave a little piece of a man in
there for our entertainment and I feel a
little guilty about,
what's crazy is there's
no talk about Steve Bay.
Steve paid the most accomplished
heavyweight of all time.
He's the greatest in terms
of like his accomplishments.
He defended the title more than anybody.
He didn't fight the best guys in their
prime when he fought junior and junior
was definitely past as promised.
The knock on him.
Right.
It's like the only fight for doom crime.
That's not his it,
but again,
when,
when it was his run during his era,
Steve Bay's the best he said,
but it was caned during his era.
He was the best fader was the best.
It's hard to say this guy has been in
this guy because it's just a different
time period.
Right.
Jordan better than Lebron
Jordan during that era.
By far the best,
the Brown right now,
by far the best.
It's stupid.
We don't know each other for,
I don't know.
Anyhow,
so that's,
that's the question about Steve Pays.
Like why,
why is there no talk
about him fighting again?
Like why have they not
set something he's trying.
He's like,
he even tweeted,
he goes DC before he retired.
Let's do it,
man.
Like quit waiting for John.
Let's do it.
Well,
he's being really active
on social media trying to,
but it doesn't seem like there's a lot
cause he has to be because you know why
it's not in his nature.
We know that's not steep,
but we know that that's not
Steve Bay's a firefighter.
Humble blue collar dude.
He's going to put in work.
Comes to fight all the time.
So Derrick Lewis explains
turning down Steve Bay fight.
Derrick says they wanted me to
fight steep and short notice.
I wanted some time off.
I would still fight Steve Pay,
but not right now.
Not so soon.
Specially after you're fighting a guy
like DC who's more of a wrestler thing
going to fight steep pay.
I know I wanted some time off.
So they tried getting steep a fight.
So they were trying to
get them for the UFC.
He's a Brooklyn car this weekend.
Nothing,
uh,
was that this weekend scene,
but it's smart of Derek Lewis.
They,
when you go DC then Steve Bay,
there couldn't be two
worst matchups for him.
He's going to get paid to beatings.
You're going to take,
you know,
it's likely unless you connect slack,
Derrick Lewis is doing it for the money.
He says that,
you know what,
I'm trying to make cash man.
So that'd be the best way to do it.
But if she's not healthy,
just give me an ass
whooping from Steve Bay.
Yeah.
Or he connects,
cracked.
That's early on.
But even Francis connected with steeper
and steeper eight does not give a
bodies.
That's how freaky is.
Yeah.
He's tough as shit,
which is more incredible.
Even that DC took 'em out,
so them offering steep bay,
um,
black bees,
you can tell they're not even thinking DC.
Steepy rebadge I know he's,
he's getting Jones Lesnar.
That's,
that's it.
I don't think lessors fighting.
I don't either.
I think some suspects going on there.
I would be willing to bet dcs last
fight is that heavyweight against John
Against Jon Jones.
It's the biggest fight of all time.
That's such a I like,
and I'm a Brock Lesnar fan.
I like,
like,
I like when he fights,
he's such a freak.
I celebrate the guy.
I don't want to let you start hating
Novasky go get a cup of coffee on Brock
fights.
I don't give a fuck.
But when,
uh,
when you talk about Jon Jones DC that,
I mean no one's even talking
about proc Jon Jones,
DC.
That's the motherfucking fuck.
I think that's bigger
than Conor could be too.
I think it's,
there's so much history there.
It's for fucking the habit.
And I think at DC at
heavyweight fight and John the,
the gap narrows,
but at light heavyweight DC,
it's not for you at heavyweight though.
And I think that's why
John's kind of like,
I'll fight them has to be at light
heavyweight because DC does have some
advantages that heavyweight now,
but let's,
let's look at what they've done with
Tj Dillashaw dropping him down to
flyweight.
Why can't DC do the same thing when
he gets down to the light heavyweight?
What do you mean?
Oh,
just saying what do you mean?
Well,
he struggled so hard to get down to the
light heavyweight that it fucks with.
His cardio is conditioning.
He just doesn't feel the same.
He says it takes too much out of him.
He feels so much stronger at heavyweight
because he doesn't have to go through
that weight cut.
Big Dude,
man.
Absolutely.
No,
no.
He's got body fat on him.
Got Extra body fat.
That's not,
it doesn't aid your performance.
Now wait,
that doesn't diminish himself or is he
a mesomorph where he's different because
sometimes like a fade or
[inaudible] or or Roy,
Roy Nelson.
If though you sh,
if you make those guys shred it,
that's not in their DNA.
They're not ectomorphs.
That's not,
you can't do that,
but because we see guys
like Francis and Ghana,
we assume that,
you know what I'm saying?
Like ectomorph is the like real skinny,
super skinny Mesomorph
is what you're thinking.
That's in the middle.
That's what I'm saying.
Don't like.
I think DC's a mezzo more morph as fat,
right?
Yes.
I think for DC,
like being shredded,
his body doesn't function off,
but it doesn't have to be shredded,
but he's carrying around
so much extra weight,
like heavy marching dudes.
Well,
he starts look at Cain Velasquez.
He just starts to guys,
he starts steep a who he just connected
with a beautiful shot in the clinch.
That's a skill as wrestling.
I think what's going on at heavyweight
with DC as he's not weakened,
let them eat whatever the fuck
he wants and he's not weakened.
I think that is critical for him and
I think when he gets done the light
heavyweight,
I think he's weakened.
I think it takes something out of them,
but I wonder how much they could mitigate
that with great diet and planning it
out the same way Colivida
has done to to to Tj,
smaller guy naturally and leaner sent
100% but still they leaned him out further
to get him down to 135
pounds before the weight cut.
I just don't think it's in
a dcs DNA to be that lean.
It's just not for him.
Maybe it's just not,
you know,
maybe,
but I think everyone benefits
from scientific planning,
meal planning,
real analysis of your calories
in calories out nutrients.
I don't know,
maybe he does that.
I bet he does that some degree.
But some guys I think do better where for
a guy like DC where he just that extra
fat and it's just,
that's his thing.
I hope that they fight.
If they do fight,
I hope the first fight
is that heavyweight.
That's 100% because we've seen the light
heavyweight cause they've talked about
doing it at light heavyweight and we've
seen the likes of John Watson at light
heavyweight.
Yeah,
well John Lott said at light heavyweight
so that it never has to appear that he
picked up a title when they took it away
from the champion that didn't earn it
from the champ.
And I get that.
But how great would it be if
you're John where you know,
most people clearly know he's beat DC.
Then you go to heavyweight
and take that from him.
It's just the ultimate fuck you.
But I also think DC's a different
animal and heavyweight and his power is
different than John does get hit in DC
at heavyweight could land some shit.
Yeah,
that's the base.
Not Easy to knock out at all.
No,
that would be the fight.
But it's also like they get
so emotional with each other.
They hate each.
Yeah.
DC.
He fucking hates that guy.
That's why paper viewed ghost,
like that's what you want that
especially at heavyweight you,
it's hard to sell a trilogy yet.
Light heavyweight,
July,
July 4th that one's weekend.
You see DC versus John Jones,
the heavyweight championship of the world.
Champ champ,
champ,
boom.
Oh giant paper view.
3 million buys prior around the area.
People are a lot of papers is,
but yeah,
there's a lot of it can be done and
that that's what's going to happen.
Dana's gonna make an
offer they can't refuse.
Well,
we're in January,
February,
March,
April,
May,
June,
July,
six months from now.
You want to retire in March?
I don't.
You know what?
It's not going to be June,
July.
It's not going to retire in March.
That's he said his force.
What?
Its 40th birthday.
He's going to retire.
I can't have it here.
That's why it's steep.
Tweet him was like,
dude let's do this before you get out.
What is this?
This is from a promo for wrestling,
the wrestling event this week cause he's
in the royal rumble at the end of the
month.
Is this,
knew him as just like current him
do think or well it's current him.
He ain't passing any tests?
No it's just a couple.
Pecos Bros.
Relax.
Look at the size of them.
There's another little,
he's a freak though,
you know?
Well he's definitely a freak but is he
physically the st like look up Brock
Lesnar lean.
So I trying to find a new picture.
You ever seen a picture
of him in high school?
Do you have jacked?
Huge.
Yeah he had a giant actually giant dude.
Ultra large size a can
of paint for a head.
He's so busy tank.
He looks like every bully of all time
in high school but he's actually a nice
guy.
Yeah like there he looks pretty lean.
That's old.
Did you ever hear about the story?
Pat Barry was telling me this.
He used to train with Brock.
Good God,
that's a freak.
Um,
when they were,
they were there in between camp and
Brock had his daughter and his hand and
people saw him and went to grab and take
pictures and he's holding his daughter
and they grabbed the hand.
He's holding his daughter and he just
went off on this dude and he's like the
nicest guy ever.
Uproxy always great.
But I guess this fan was like,
oh my God,
Brock Lesnar.
And he's like,
Yo,
I'm with my kids,
man.
Don't bother me.
And some dude was like,
Nah,
let's do you get a picture and grabs
him and he's holding his daughter and it
just went,
he just was like,
what the fuck are you doing?
Man grabbed his arm while
he's holding his daughter.
He sold this down like this and the,
that's why.
Yeah,
that's,
she remind me and grabbed me.
He's like,
what the fuck,
dude?
I get my daughter,
you're a man and I'm Brock Lesnar.
I'm gonna Twist your head off.
People want what they want.
And they don't care.
I just don't see him fighting again.
I'd be happy if I was wrong.
I think he definitely wants
to get back in there again.
I mean I think he has some,
some fights in his mind that
he would like to get back.
I think it's been,
I think you could beat Cain 95%
of the division to freak man.
He is a freak.
You know Pico grams.
No Pico.
Great.
He's a fucking freak.
Did he could cramps.
That's just my reference
for fucking steroids now.
A Pico Pico.
So hot right now.
He's such a freak.
He is.
Do you want some skeptical
Hipaa wise for your boy?
Novitsky how about the test results for
Lesner showed up then went away on their
website and they're like,
oh,
it's just a,
just a random mistake.
It's just a glitch.
That 50,000 took care of.
How funny is that?
I wonder what happened?
What do you think happened?
I don't know.
I literally,
I do not know.
I,
there's some sort of shakiness there.
Oh,
come on man.
If you think you saw it as the end all
be all your goddamn on technical issues
caused online block
Brock Lesnar drug tests,
number discrepancy.
Here's my prom,
Joe.
Here's my problem with this.
So let's just assume Brock,
I don't know,
has he had a needle in his ass?
Maybe.
Maybe I'm not.
I don't know.
I've never done it 100% I would guess.
Well he tested positive
in the Mark Hunt fight.
Correct.
And mark suing them for that.
So,
so he's marked suing him.
Mark soon in the UFC still.
He's still a legal
action with interesting.
Yeah.
And he's,
and he's not in the UFC.
He's his contract's up with UFC.
So it's could probably
get even gnarlier now.
So good luck to Mark Hunt.
But,
so Brock Lesnar,
we know steroid user,
his tasks,
what?
It just doesn't show up.
I mean that's random.
But what,
that's coincidence John John's
greatest fighter of all time.
You saw the issues.
Pico grams.
That's just a coincidence.
It's too much of a coincidence for me.
Okay.
But wait a minute,
the Jon Jones you sought of
thing they tested and positive.
Correct?
Like,
what are you saying,
by the way,
did test negative after the
fight even for the metabolites.
So heat for the Pico grams afterwards.
So there's no pico gardens.
You're saying Pico grants?
Pico grams is a unit of measurement.
Correct.
What he tested positive for?
There were no peacock volite for this,
this,
this steroid,
which,
and after the fight there was nothing.
Correct.
Right.
Okay.
Cause the numbers,
they're there.
What they're saying is that what he,
what his body has in it is
a response to this sterile.
It's not detecting like
Anna Var in his system,
whether detecting is it's a metabolite.
Correct.
Or detecting,
is the body responding to the fact that
this steroid had been in his system
previously?
Yes.
But they,
they dashikis coincidence.
Yeah.
It's not that it's a co you
keep saying it like it's a joke.
But the situation to me is a,
I look at it.
Okay,
well why don't you tell
me why it's a joke.
This is why it's a joke.
Because have you ever heard of any,
and before I say all this Jones is I
think whether he did anything or not.
He's still the greatest
fighter on the planet.
He doesn't need this stuff.
The reason to me,
cause it's a joke is because the greatest
fighter on the planet to ever enter
the octagon has all these issues to him.
He's too much of a coincidence to me.
He has plenty of issues outside of that.
When you say all of these issues,
you mean steroid issue?
Correct.
Right now first one being the Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
I don't mean to cut you off,
but the first one being the
excuse of the Dick Pills.
Okay.
But,
but it was like they
actually got the Dick Pills.
They tested them.
This is all documented.
Is it?
Cause they will those data in finals,
it pills Joe,
they felt what they found
were the precursors that
can be found in Dick Pills.
So if it's Clenbuterol Emma,
what do you mean when
you're talking about,
so,
so the,
the thing that he flagged for
those do show up in Dick Pills.
Yeah.
They also show up in
a lot of other things.
Right.
But he got them the Dick Pills that
he took and they had it in them.
Correct.
So that means he,
so then he would cook.
But in the amount that
he had in his system,
what they're saying is the only way
that could exist is through a tainted
supplement.
The way they tested them before,
the way they tested them after the wet,
the small window of time where
he was positive for that thing,
there'd be no performance
enhancing benefit for him
to take something in a micro
dose or whatever.
And that it's in such a small amount
that it had to be a tainted supplement.
They got them the actual
supplement that he took,
the Dick pill supplement,
it had it in it that contained that
sick and he got punished for that.
This is not like a steroid that he took
were made him a better fighter or made
him a better athlete.
So to play devil's advocate here so
that that stuff that comes in those dick
pills and you can get from other steroids,
but it happens to be in those days,
you certainly can.
Correct.
But,
but that's one narrative that you took
clear that you could say what's in these
Dick Pills?
I'm not saying,
I'm saying I just can't do that.
That's true.
But it's in such a small amount in his
body and it wasn't in his body before and
it wasn't in his body after which showed
that it was only in his body and an
extremely small amounts
for a small window,
but a small window of time.
So it's not like he had,
it's not even like this stuff,
which is a metabolite which is
showing a response to the body,
the body responding to the steroids.
And let me ask this Joe.
Okay.
Why does no other fighter have any Pico
Pico grants that this pulsating effect
really?
Well,
that's not true.
I mean other fighters had tested,
Frank Mir tested positive
for something two years.
Tom Lawler test it,
but Frank Mir didn't go through
the same steps that Jon Jones did.
He didn't provide them with a,
I forget what the exact there was.
There was something that John did also
that lowered his sentencing and it was
covered.
He was an informant.
Yes.
It was cooperating with Usada.
Yeah.
Or,
or agreeing to cooperate with Usada.
Yeah.
That was were just cool with that.
Listen,
I don't even know what that means.
I don't either.
But let me ask you this.
If I agreed to Usada to be an informant,
snitches get stitches.
Correct.
But unless you're John,
then no one can beat you up,
so you're fine.
But the thing is,
is
the only way I can inform
you is if something that,
uh,
of that,
um,
knowing that I know of,
I can inform you of Joseph.
That speculation.
That was what I asked Novitsky I was like,
if he didn't do anything wrong,
like,
and what is he going to offer?
Because if,
unless he took something,
unless you know what you're doing.
Like if I'm an informant for the
FBI or for the feds for cocaine,
right.
I know my cocaine.
Right.
They're not going to get Joe blow.
That makes my fucking express so we can
get the guy who knows the ins and outs
of cocaine.
Right.
That's again,
that's I'm like,
all right,
cool.
More.
They have a conversation with him
and he says he can provide them with
information with how guys are getting
away with passing truck to and how would
you know about that
unless you're in on that?
No,
I don't either.
I'm just saying again,
to me all of his is a little too much of
coincidence that the best fight on the
planet earth has these issues.
The best fight in the planner is also
ran away from a hit and run smash into a
girl and broke her arm.
He also drove his car into a tree.
He's a reckless person who takes
a lot of chances and he does some,
at least in the past has done some
things that are not very wise.
This could social under that or
it could fall is correct or two.
I began to play devil's advocate.
I'm not accusing them of anything.
Play Devil's advocate or a guy who was
that Lucy Goosey outside the AUC gun
might have taken some performance
enhancing things cause that would be the
similar traits could have
except in this situation.
It doesn't line up with the facts
of what he took in terms of longterm
metabolites,
short term metabolites and
medium term metabolize.
The only,
the only lonely,
only longterm metabolites existed,
which means that whatever he took,
he had to have taken a long time ago.
Now the problem with this is this
all comes from that Guy Gregory re,
re Cenk office,
and I say his name.
You're talking about the one test.
The,
what I'm talking about is a study that
shows these metabolites is all from this
one individual.
This guy Grigory were Cenk Goff,
who was the man from that documentary.
ICARUS.
He used to work for the Russian doping,
the state sponsored doping program.
He's the one who established these tests.
And the way he established
his test is very,
uh,
highly criticized by people because,
well,
it's not suspect it's,
but it's criticized by people
because he injected himself and,
and test that all these
metabolites on himself.
And this is not been done on any peer
reviewed test outside of his research.
Um,
it hasn't been duplicated.
The problem is it's not legal to perform
these sorts of tests on people in
America.
You can't just shoot people up with
illegal steroids in America and find out
what it does to them and they'll do that.
I told him to get Sean Shelby whack
'em up with a bunch of steroids.
Just test for Sean's down for,
he wants to get bigger,
just do it or just do it to veto
bell wherever he's fighting,
just set him down,
tell him,
look veto,
we've got an extra couple of
hundred grand for you on the side.
It's just do this and let us do
some plugging up with Dick Pills.
See how it goes,
Bro.
Fucking cocaine tainted creating for real.
He would do it.
Yeah.
I don't know,
man.
I'm,
I,
I maintain an open mind.
I do too.
I'm not accusing John Anything,
but again,
for me,
and this is just me,
it's too much of a coincidence,
coincidence for it to raise
some red flags from me.
Glide tried to,
to independent scientists outside
of Novitsky where I was sending guys
information.
They were sending me back or saying
them all the work that they did.
I send them all the
relevant studies and uh,
one of them who was suspicious initially
after reviewing all this stuff decided
that it doesn't seem like it's likely
that it could be possible that he could
have actually cheated.
He said it's more like she did during
that time more likely that the actual,
the tainted supplement excuse is,
and by the way,
the team tainted supplement,
I'm using the air quotes
supplement was never provided.
That supplement was never provided.
So unless they did it
to Usada and he cited,
didn't want to release it,
the number one question was,
was it cocaine that was
tainted with creatine?
That was the,
that was where people thought it came
from because it's really co according to
Novitsky when he was
working for the government,
that would be a really common thing that
creatine was used in cocaine to cut it
because it looks like coke.
It cuts with coke.
It's normal.
It's not toxic.
So they would always mix in cheap
creotine with cocaine to make more coke.
Makes Sense.
Yeah,
it makes sense.
And he,
that's what,
that's what Novitsky believed,
but that's not what he believed.
But he believed that was a possibility.
I've heard all sorts of possibilities.
Yeah.
It'd be interesting to
know the actual truth.
Yeah.
Well you know,
we do not going to know that.
I think we know as much as we're going
to know unless John comes out was John
retires and it's like,
you know,
I had,
I had a doctor and he would stick it
in my fingernails and see him slowly
release.
Yeah.
With some high advance microdose.
He would never admit that though.
Nobody ever admits it
unless they get caught.
It tarnish your legacy unless
it's like an MLB thing.
But so many people were
quick to jump on the,
he's a cheater bandwagon.
I'm like,
man,
it got you gotta be careful.
I gotta be careful with that.
Yeah,
be careful of that.
But also you've got to
be careful with that.
But also you should be suspicious.
You should be suspicious.
I don't think that if when
you saw the Novitsky go,
it's all good man.
It was a date pill.
You Go,
cool man,
I don't,
I don't think you can do that.
Well they definitely didn't do that.
He,
he,
he lost a lot of money.
But the fans do.
That's what the fans do.
You know,
some people can do that.
I think it's okay to go.
God I,
it's just,
I don't know man.
Like it's too much smoke here for me.
It's okay to do that.
What it's not okay do is
to say he was cheating.
He's,
you know,
he's busted.
So the only reason these wires,
you have this stuff in his system,
that one,
no,
it's fine to say,
why's he have this stuff in the system?
Well,
this is what I said,
but they showed why he had an assistant.
Yeah,
but doesn't mean you should
have it in your system now.
He definitely,
she's not cool to have it in the system.
No,
no.
So it's okay to go.
Why the fuck is in the best fighter in
the world system and then what are you
doing,
dude?
That's fine.
There's some shit that's going on right
now that they haven't figured out yet.
That's going to be revealed.
We leave you shit cited.
I think so.
The the,
the drugs,
those then that underworld
is always ahead of the,
of the testing.
Always.
That's what Novitsky said at first,
but now he thinks it's reached this
point where the testing is so good.
Do you know the testing threshold that
he tested positive for for the peak of
grams is five two to 5,000 times
stronger than the Wata threshold?
Yeah.
So He'd have 2000 to 5,000 times more
of it in his system or 2000 to five
thousand two thousand percent
numbers are tough to keep up with.
I don't remember.
Andy Foster told me what it was either
way but an insane amount of much higher
quantities.
This shit for him to test
positive and water like these,
these tests that they use now are insane.
Some of the doctors in the undergrads now,
this is the thing
they're doing well maybe,
but this is the thing they're doing now.
Well,
the thing is like if it's so low,
you're not going to have a
performance enhancing benefits.
It has to actually be in your system in
order to have a performance enhancing
benefit.
But now in 2019 they are
actually considering lowering
their standards so that
say if you do take some creatine and it
does have the tiniest trace amount of
Austrian or something like that,
that's not going to show
up positive and him,
which is how maybe they should do it
because it's so strict now where it's,
it's tainting guys legacy.
You look at Josh Barnett,
you look at Frank Mir,
this barn,
that's another one where
they eventually cleared him,
but Jesus Christ took
a year fucked up man.
And then on top of that,
everybody knew that he was under
suspicion and Josh has tested positive for
four.
So everybody assumed that he
was doing something fucked them.
Novitsky told me that the stuff,
the testing is so good now that if you
and I were in this room and I had a jar
of creating that had steroids in it and
I popped it open and the fucking dust
got in the air and we ingested that dust,
we would both test positive
from opening a jar in a room.
And that's crazy good for them.
But I think there's the Elan Musk
of steroid pds out there who's like,
yeah,
cool man.
You guys are testing for this.
We're over here.
You dumb ass.
His bed.
He's got a lot of y's and z's
and his name and had cheese.
Yeah.
It's just push.
Just fuck.
It was like a glass house.
Hell yeah.
Probably dead as we're speaking.
They probably shot him and sleep now.
Yeah,
I mean they still applies to
all or did you see a Chris,
did you see that insane man?
A second.
I know the lengths people go to with the
whole Russian anti doping program was
horseshit.
They were just doping people,
state sponsored doping,
and that the fact that they had rigged
the Sochi Olympics so that they,
they got fake piss.
And you think that the only
country doing that China did it.
Oh for sure.
They still did it on the paging.
China's like they were breaking gold,
red gold medals.
And I think it's funny
how people are like,
this is ridiculous.
How could Russia do it?
I'm like,
oh my God,
everyone.
Or even with John,
like I don't,
I don't eat,
let's say John did do some illegal shit
that we don't know and he got away.
I don't give a fuck dude.
I really don't.
I think a lot of guys are doing things.
I D
I think it's part of
every professional sport.
NFL,
NBA,
Nhl,
especially fighting.
It's just,
that's the nature of the beast.
Well,
it's certainly a nature.
I mean it's definitely a,
comes with the territory.
It's definitely far
sports because it works.
You know what's interesting is like why
is it okay to take regular creatine,
regular creatine works probably
as good as micro dosing.
Any of this bullshit where be surprised,
but yeah.
Yeah.
I think they,
there's some microdosing shit out there
that the NFL guys can get their hands on
or MLB that you're like,
God damn well they say that micro dosing,
actual testosterone is more effective
because microdosing actual testosterone
doesn't produce any random weird
metabolites and that's what God was doing.
He had like gummy bears
were riding a four.
He'd bat and he's like,
pop this gummy bear,
this bag.
Hold on.
And then by the time
test them after the game.
He's good.
That's so crazy.
So crazy.
How much did they take
away from him after that?
Oh my God,
man.
His,
the whole legacy was tarnished.
Were were you with me in Vegas Time?
We at Strip steak house and a rod was
there and he was like to smoke shows and
no one like,
everyone's like really?
That fucking guy.
Where are you there with me?
Oh No,
I forget everyone at the table's like
fuck back and like why he's awesome.
Like do all the steroids and like,
yeah,
played baseball.
Everyone's on steroids.
You hate him because of that.
That's a funny thing though,
that you're a cheater thing.
Like that was the thing with mark
McGwire and Sammy Sosa hate to tell you,
the guy's pitching the ball to them.
Also juice to the gills.
It fuck with Sammy Sosa so much he
turned himself into a white guy and went,
fuck this noise.
I'm going white.
Go on.
Super White.
Went ultra camouflage not working cause
he sticks out even more now he's still
doing interviews and she
dresses what is going on.
No,
he does interviews but just
assumed like it's all good.
He's like dressing up like
the plant and makes sense man.
Yeah he is.
And then when someone brings it up,
he's like,
what?
What do,
what do you mean what's
wrong with this guy?
And I just used the lotion
that people are like,
well you're white bro.
And he's like,
what about it?
Yeah,
I like to look like this.
Like no,
I know.
But what the fuck are you doing?
He's like,
leaching yourself with
just straight up low shit.
Do you think he has spots on his
back that he can't reach now?
I bet as girls and she's like,
dude,
we can't have these fucking spots.
Like your Goddamn
Dalmatian back of his dude.
Hop out his dead.
There's no way all his
dick wrinkles aren't black.
Like you're not going to get all that
probably looks like help drain the
whitening stuff.
Do you have to to get all the
nooks and crannies of the day?
You don't have the tape.
Do you get your asshole bleached could
match if you have a black hole for an
asshole like everything else is.
There's just spots all over
something to think about fro.
It's just,
Oh wow,
look how wide he is.
He doesn't look bad there,
but it looks like he's wearing makeup.
Felt good.
He looks like like we got
them Dick Tracy character.
It looks weird because you know what?
Like the inside of his eyelids,
like that's dark.
You know what I'm saying?
Because you can't really
get the whitening cream.
He looks like a God van Pyre.
You can't get the whitening cream to your,
well,
if he was a regular guy and
that's what he looked like,
that'd be normal.
I mean that's like Joey Diaz,
the skin color,
but it's like you get to his eyeliner,
go to his eyeballs,
make that larger.
Like look around.
His eye is dark and his ear lobes.
Oh,
that's weird.
The ear lobes are freaking me out,
but at the end,
the inside of his nostrils.
Oh yeah.
You can't look at the darkness.
It's a nightmare.
Well,
Hey,
strange.
He digs it.
I guess he likes you to,
how bout happy?
How bout,
how hard were we howling at Joey Diaz
story the other night at the comedy store?
Mark,
I'm telling you,
you fucked up my ribs.
That's what he used to look like.
Oh my gosh.
She was a black guy.
Oh yeah,
black cube did he held court last
night to same spot on the kitchen.
Oh my God.
He told a story about him taking a shit.
I sent me a picture of his shit.
Me Too.
The next morning we woke up,
he sent us pictures of his shit.
He goes,
this is
stop about how he,
how he's eating.
This isn't a bit right.
He's that he's eating sauerkraut and
farting on the crane and Lauren hills.
Like,
what the fuck man,
dude.
Yeah.
I was floored.
I was sweating in my mind.
I'm telling you.
That's why I woke up.
I'm like,
did I get punched in the ribs?
Like,
oh no fucking,
I texted her.
I'm like,
dude,
your story.
Fuck my ribs up.
Last night I had a runaway.
I was about to go on stage.
I had a runaway from him before because
I wouldn't have been able to think about
when material.
Oh,
I would have a think about
what you're talking about.
I was laughing so hard.
He's the goat.
I gotta wrap this on my bed.
You get the fuck out.
You got the FBI guy.
CIA.
Yeah.
A little different than me.
Huh?
Maybe talk to him about fucking Pecos.
See what he says about them.
I'm all out picos right now.
I don't know why I can't.
It's just in my head.
Well,
it's,
it's a fun thing to run with and if it's,
he's like,
Jesus Christ show shut
the full Saturday night.
San Diego.
You'd be surprised.
I know Brendan motherfucking
Shab Showtime Special.
That's right.
I'm running my one hour at flappers
in Burbank the night before on Friday.
Then you've been banging it out,
man.
You've been hitting the road hard Edmonton
everywhere you've been tr Torin grind
and punching it in.
Yes sir.
They excited.
I can't wait Saturday night.
We'll see ya.
Bye.
Or Buddy.
Okay.